Hello.
God mind.
Guys...
I woke up and my throat hurt.
Oh gosh.
Made turquoise?
Loves this more than made mint?
Who is that?
I'll be one year away from 30 this Sunday.
Am I old?
Because I feel old and brittle.
You're not old until you're old and cranky.
Probably.
Do you feel like telling kids to get off your lawn?
Todd Bell!
He's really gifted.
There's a weird ghost on the TV.
So Minto old?
Are you saying I'm cranky?
It's okay, Barn.
Thank you.
Ghost only Pokemon run.
Scarlet Violet is your best bet.
Open world?
You have access to most of the ghosts from the start.
NPC even trades you a Gengar early on?
Also, do you guys like me being in a box?
I figured it's better than me floating in the void.
But also, I'm not covering up so much.
Maybe.
I might have to reduce my head a little bit.
I'm the box ghost.
Just a box.
I'm eating a cough drop.
And I forgot to eat breakfast, so we might talk for a little bit and listen to whatever this ambiance is until it's time for me to start.
For breakfast, I have an egg.
I have an egg that I must peel.
They have an egg peeling instructions.
Congrats on 215,000!
Thank you!
Did you know that your eyes in CB form kind of look like acorns?
Hot dog?
No, Murphy.
I don't have any hot dogs.
But I also have a onigiri.
But it's like a healthy onigiri.
With barley and edamame and salted kelp.
They do look like acorns.
You're not gonna crack me open, are you?
Ghost containment box.
No, no, no.
This is not for my...this is not for my safety.
It's for yours.
Hold on, my...
I don't know what's...oh, it's because I moved my...okay.
I moved some stuff around on my desk and I'm not feeling it.
But, you know, we'll see.
I also...it has occurred to me that I'm playing a horror game.
Usually I have to kind of like psych myself up for these.
And here I go, just going in raw.
Like a dog.
JPEG dog was very happy with your achievement.
I got that dog in it.
I got that dog in me.
Been to that Lawson.
Oh, see that Lawson is doing a collab with Blue Archive.
I did!
I did.
I did see that.
But the merch that I do want from the Blue Archive Lawson...oh my gosh.
Please, Discord.
Why don't...why does...
Why does streamer mode not work for you?
I'm literally streaming.
Is it Mata?
No, this time it's Barry.
She's doing this GTA RP thing.
And I'm actually in the server.
But I didn't realize that it would be starting when I was in Japan.
So I don't think I can join.
Let's go!
Next season, maybe.
But I'm also...I was like...I don't know if I...why does it not work though?
For real.
She's showing me an oil rig.
Hold on, I'm just gonna close out of Discord.
Sorry Barry, I'll respond to you later.
Um...I'm getting paranoid with every ping.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
What was I saying though?
Heard her talking about it earlier, wondering if you were gonna join.
Yeah, I uh...
I uh...wanted to.
But also, I'm like...so...I kinda...earlier, right before stream, I joined a...they were all in call.
And I joined, but I literally couldn't say anything.
I was like...
Okay, I'm following these instructions on how to peel this egg, and it is not...
working.
This is not the run.
This is...
I'm literally going...I'm having to go like...little piece by piece.
I don't remember what I was saying though.
Oh!
The Blue Archive Lawson.
Yes, I saw it, but...oh my gosh.
There are plushies that I really want.
I really want the Hina plushie.
But it's online order only.
The other stuff I'm okay with.
I'll probably still get something.
Just cause I want to be like...I got Blue Archive.
The shell is full of calcium.
Don't lie to me.
I'm gullible.
You need instructions to peel an egg?
Well, I was trying to see if there was an optimal way of peeling.
And it said like, crack the top and the bottom, and then it will split down the middle.
That did not happen.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Depends on the boiled egg too?
Or maybe...
I'm like halfway there.
Kinda.
Stopping by quickly cause I'm currently on route to New York City!
So many people are going to New York!
So excited to see you in concert!
Gonna be at Breaking Dimensions too.
I'll be sure to cheer Wawa and Fumoko for you boss.
Yeah!
Thank you!
Hello ghost lady.
Hello, hello!
Supplementary streamlabs because Berry stomped on my birthday streamlabs with her discord pics!
Oh!
I'm sorry!
Oh my god.
Magic Sword King!
Happy Birthday!
If you're streaming on Saturday...
You can ignore this.
I'm...well...maybe...
No.
I don't...I might be streaming Saturday...your time.
Actually I'm not sure.
Maybe...actually I can't...I don't know my schedule yet actually.
But happy birthday!
You know I was just thinking now just in case.
You know?
Because I got the concert...
And I have some other things planned that I gotta go do.
So...uh...it's like...time zones are confusing the heck out of me.
They're confusing the heck out of me.
Anyway, let me sing for you.
Oh!
Don't drop my egg!
Happy Birthday to you!
Happy Birthday Magic Sword King!
And also Hideo Kojima!
Happy Birthday to you!
I didn't know Kojima's birthday was on Saturday!
Wow!
And you share...do you share a little bit of his genius?
Mmm!
Eggie!
Mwah!
His dreams...
Does he know welcome to membership?
Sorry, if you're just coming in, I'm eating my breakfast first.
And then we'll start the game.
What you should have done is make a small hole at the top of the egg, bigger hole at the bottom, then blow through the top and shoot it out?
Wait, really?
But if you shoot it out, how do you catch it?
Where would it go?
How far would it shoot?
Does not work.
But does work.
I don't think that works on a hard boiler.
Oh.
Enjoy your meal.
Have you heard of the horror genre convention called...
SAWCON?
Yeah!
I'm a guest every year, didn't you know?
I'm like the SAWCON representative.
What is that profile picture?
Who changed it?
I'm here.
Where am I?
I took the weekend off.
Work, wait.
Weekend off, work for the two concerts.
Let's go!
And glued to my bed for the rest of the evening watching the stream because the trip was a lot longer than I expected.
Okay, I think I'm good with the egg just for now.
Oh my gosh.
I got these other things at 7-Eleven.
And it's like... it's called... it's like baked chocolate.
And then it's also strawberry and blueberry flavored.
And it is... oh my gosh.
It is some of the... oh my god, it is so...
It's way better than... I was like, baked chocolate?
Like... that's... that's interesting.
I've never heard of that.
Like... you know?
But it tastes like a brownie.
It is the... oh my gosh.
Before I leave, I'm going to be buying like 50 of these.
Because they're so good!
Can someone update me if Mint got her wallet yet?
I did!
Yeah, I did!
I got it on Monday.
But yeah, I was just like, I wonder what a baked chocolate tastes like.
I'm gonna eat it right now.
I don't know.
It's so good.
Yummy, yummy, yummy.
So if you... go to Japan or in Japan, and you go to 7-Eleven, get the baked chocolate.
Chocolate.
It's baked.
Yeah.
I mean...
Unrelated, but there's this omelette that...
this one restaurant I go to makes.
And it's got a runny egg in the middle.
And I've tried to replicate it, but it never turns out.
I don't... I don't care how they do it.
Like a French toast?
Chocolate buns.
Thank you!
Hashtag not sponsored.
Yeah, hashtag not sponsored.
It was... it's just that delicious.
And they're like small enough that like...
I can eat one...
and feel fine, you know?
And not feel bad.
But I also only need to eat one.
I've been like munching on them the past week.
I just have one a day.
How many do I have left in here?
Only three!
Uh oh.
I'm gonna have to go get some more.
I want some more.
Okay, let me take a sippy of my tea.
Why would you feel bad?
You know what?
You can never eat like...
too many chocolates and feel bad.
Yeah, Isamori is talking about Sakon like it's a real thing.
No, I don't mean like tummy whore.
I mean like guilty.
Like you're just like, oh no.
I should have never eaten all of those.
Oh no.
Like bad physically or mentally?
Mentally, mentally, mentally.
Not bad physically.
Okay.
Spooky and scary.
Why is this game so dark?
Okay, my brightness is all the way up.
And it's still so dark.
Brownie finds thank you!
It's completely cooked.
But then you cut into it and it's a delicious runny egg.
They serve it on French bread.
This is not French toast!
It's my favorite thing outside the Rum Chata French...
Oh my god.
That's my wake up alarm.
Alright.
So, where did we last leave off?
We were starting night...
Oh gosh, I'm gonna have to remember how to play the game.
Alright, let's just continue.
Starting day three.
The frightening.
I don't know how...
I am going to try and finish the game today.
So...
You know.
Might be a little bit longer of a stream.
French toast is very different.
F to reload the flashlight.
Oh yes!
We're gonna go...
Yes, we just woke up.
We're gonna go find mom.
Why can't I pet the cat?
There we go.
This window is also boarded up.
Thanks Springtrap.
Hammered shut.
So I guess for this last night...
We will have to...
Oh my god.
Already followed that thing once.
Didn't go so well last time.
My favorite chocolate that I only sell seasonal and I'm super sad.
I'm a Cadbury egg addict.
That's the stuff with like the cream in the middle, right?
What if I do follow him?
Oh, not falling for that again.
Better go the long way around.
Okay.
But then...
Let's do a little bit of a recap.
We go into a pit.
First of all, we are Oswald.
And we're just some kid that like...
Is kind of ungrateful sometimes.
But he's growing on me.
He's growing on me a little bit.
He just has bad opinions, I think.
And...
He...
Um...
Went to a pizza place.
His dad dropped him off.
And then he went into the armpit.
And traveled through time.
Oh, great mid of the turquoise box.
What is your wisdom?
Turquoise and mint are closer colors than I thought.
Sorry, the ball pit.
The ball pit, not the armpit.
He went into the ball pit.
And traveled through time.
And he became...
He became really loyal to some kids he just met like...
For two minutes.
And so we've been going back and forth through time.
Um...
Because also our dad got pulled into the ball pit by Springtrap.
And we're searching for him.
And Springtrap has replaced our dad in the present.
And so...
Yeah.
That's about it.
Basically it.
And our Springtrap as our...
Oh, wait.
Sorry.
I just noticed the notifs like are kind of cut off.
Um...
He like sits with us at dinner.
And it's really funny.
I like that part.
Mom!
Do all ball pits take you through time?
Possibly.
Ew!
Dad's underwear!
Alright.
I wonder if you do this enough times if Uboa shows up.
Oh!
Flick the light switch ten times.
I'm super mega excited about the concert.
Sunday!
I'm gonna jam my heart out.
Yeah!
Thank you!
Anything in here?
I'm looking for flashlight batteries at the moment.
Grandma holding me as a baby.
Flashlight batteries.
Nothing in here.
Okay.
What concert?
I'll be performing at a concert in New York at ANYC.
Um...
This weekend?
I'm kinda curious about FNAF lore.
You should watch that one nine-hour FNAF lore video some guy did.
Maybe make it a watch-along.
Oh my god.
Um...
Scrubs.
Minto is grounded!
We had that light switch installed for you.
So you could turn the lights on and off.
Not so you could throw light switch waves.
If that thing stood here, would it be...
a rabbit in the reflection or my dad?
Oh.
We haven't seen that dialogue yet.
Oh, mom!
He said take the long way, but this is...
Wouldn't the other way be the long way?
Good morning, Oswald.
Are you ready for breakfast?
I think I'll just eat at school today, if that's okay.
Sure, honey.
Have you made any new friends yet?
Well, there is this one new guy.
I can't seem to get away from.
Springtrap?
Um...
Do I need to turn the brightness up a little bit?
Just let me know.
Now, Os.
That's not very nice.
Maybe he wants to be your friend.
Eh...
In any case, it's only your second day.
It'll get better.
You just have to take it one step at a time.
Go to school.
Found the battery!
Nice!
Nice.
This is why we...
This is why we run around.
I made a chocolate.
I've been making this chocolate cake with...
Raspberry mousse layers!
Buttercrack frost egg with a white chocolate...
Stop!
It sounds so good.
Why is it so dark in here?
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
I think I actually have to turn up the setting.
Maybe it...
Maybe like that.
So that it's easier to...
It's still so dark!
Not allowed to mess with the toolbox.
Furnace down here was the scariest.
We got rats.
It's still so dark.
Oh my god.
That rat scared me.
Anything in here?
It's worse?
I think so.
I tried to change the color contrast.
Because otherwise it's just like...
Like if you have the contrast with the brightness...
It should be better, right?
I don't know.
Anyway.
We'll see how it is later.
Cat.
Let's check if I'm being a little loot goblin.
Sorry.
Ruth Beerslayer!
Thanks.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Oh!
Jeff's number.
Wait.
Other than the pizzeria's phone number...
The notes are gibberish.
Wait.
What was it?
5-5-5-5-3-3-3.
Do I need that?
Springtrap.
Are you sitting at the dinner table?
No!
Where are you?
Is he going to ambush me?
The board games.
The year.
Calendar year.
Jinx likes to perch up there and watch over us while we eat.
Cute.
I used to have a cat that would sit with us at the dinner table.
He would like not climb on the table.
He would sit in the chair and just kind of like stare at us.
He never tried to get on the table either.
He was very polite.
I think she's just hoping we'll drop a scrap she can snack on.
But what's the year?
Can I go in here?
Oh!
Okay.
Springtrap is gone, I guess.
Trying to find...
Why do we have so many boxes?
Did we just move?
Are we moving?
What the?
Did you?
Huh?
The Freddy head!
More.
Wait.
Is it still down there?
It is!
What?
Freddy mask.
Why would anyone want to look at this thing?
Tradable item.
Oh!
Tradable.
Do I give this to the kid?
That wants something unique?
Interesting.
No!
What?
What is this?
Yeah, the fireworks guy, maybe.
Oh!
Hi, Dad!
I like how his eyes stop glowing when he...
Oh!
When she's not looking.
You might be a big sixth grader now, but you can't outrun a mom smooch.
Be good today, Oswald.
Remember that Dad and I are always here for you.
Aw, Spartan!
Welcome to the membership.
Thank you.
What about my dad's smooch?
Oh, sorry.
I can move now.
Dad, are you going to smooch me too?
Dad, please, give me a hug, Dad.
It's been so long since you...
I'm like sneaking past him.
Glow.
That's so funny.
When he looks at the mom, his eyes stop glowing.
Okay.
I'm phasing through him.
I wonder if we're ever going to visit Grandma.
We talk about her several times.
It's the only reason we're here, apparently.
So...
I wish you would believe me about Dad.
Okay.
Go to school.
What if the mom likes the dad like this, though?
What if she's like...
He's changed, but for like the better.
Oh my god.
She's freaky.
She's freaky like that.
Okay.
Let's go, let's go.
It's Oswald the Ocelot.
Looking for a place to...
To molt?
I don't...
Do you know what an ocelot is?
Huh?
I love Oswald the Ocelot.
Wait.
What the...
What do you mean, molt?
I'm not like a bug.
Ocelots don't even do that, Dylan.
I guess you'd be the expert.
And what's so bad about being an ocelot?
They're prideful creatures!
Ocelots are like, great!
I've got way bigger problems than you...
...than you today.
Oh my god!
He just slapped my butt!
What the heck
was that?
Oh my god, I'm starting to have hallucinations.
What's the matter, Oswald?
Nothing misses me, champ.
I just can't focus, I guess.
We're starting to have hallucinations...
Oh my gosh, we're starting to get really...
...really into the...
...the time travel.
Maybe you need to stretch your legs to clear your mind.
I left a book behind in the principal's office.
Would you mind getting it for me?
Get Mrs. MeChamp's book from the principal's office.
Why do I think we're going to be traveled back in time?
Why do I think something spooky is going to happen?
Don't make me go, Mrs. MeChamp!
Don't make me go!
I just want to learn my ABCs!
Also, why...
Okay, I know she's...
We're in sixth grade, right?
Why is this, like, room look like it's for kindergartners?
Only four kids in a class?
It's a small town, you know?
How can I save Dad if I can barely even get through school?
Derek played!
Thanks for the 10 gifted!
Come on, Oz.
Like Mom said, one step at a time.
I'm going to take a step and I'm going to get transported into the spooky world!
Okay.
Two steps.
Three steps.
Four steps.
Five steps.
Step, step.
Where is the principal's office?
I need to get the book from the...
Oh, here we go.
Dylan effed around and got found out.
Yeah, what a dummy.
A battery!
Oh!
Thank goodness.
Okay.
It pays being a loot demon.
Oh my gosh.
Get out of my stream, Matara-Khan!
You are just a problem to me in my everyday afterlife, aren't you?
What if I pulled that, though?
Battery, battery...
Hey, what are you doing outside of class?
I'm getting a book for Mrs. Maychamp.
Matara, please.
Wait, actually, can I turn these off?
How do I turn off the things for...
Hold on.
How do I turn this off, actually?
Settings?
Notifications?
What's a toast?
Show toast?
Maybe that's it.
Maybe I did it.
Okay.
I think.
There we go.
I think I did it.
It says toast on the steam.
This calls it a toast.
Anyway.
I'm getting a book.
No, you're not, kid.
You're helping me find the key to my office.
Oh.
Oh my god.
It's one of those, like, fetch quests.
Huh?
I got locked out of my office when I went to get a snake?
A what?
Get a what?
A snack.
I went to get a...
Huh?
What is she implying here?
Oh, a snack!
When I went to oversee student behavior.
I'll look around.
You're a lifesaver, little guy.
Okay.
Let's go find some keys.
Find the principal's keys.
Are they in this locker?
These lockers don't get used.
Not enough kids to need them since the mill closed.
What's in here?
This door is locked.
What is this?
Oh, the playground.
Okay.
Let's go check one of the classrooms.
Perhaps this one over here?
Perhaps if I leave?
Can't leave the school.
We aren't even dismissed yet.
Come on, Oswald.
Be a rebel.
Don't be a rebel.
Don't you want to just be a rebel once in your life?
Well, there's no one in here.
Snake is a snack though.
So true.
Got him.
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
I don't know why that's like the...
Scares me so much.
Something spooky is going to happen at the school.
I know it.
I'm just waiting for it.
Run, Ozzy.
Run.
Whoa.
Where did you find it?
You know, I searched almost every room in the school for that key.
Ms. Principal, there's like two...
There's actually two rooms.
There's actually two rooms in this school.
Almost every room?
I better be off.
I think I heard someone calling for me in the cafeteria.
There's a cafeteria.
And she just lets me into her office with no...
Oh.
Okay.
Hold on.
Any batteries?
Framed articles from the school newspaper.
Headlines about the time we won a kickball tournament.
What else is in here?
Any batteries?
I think that's the thing that I got whipped with earlier.
Dad would come for our parent teacher conferences.
Doubt that thing will come to those.
If I save you in the hospital, you can do it for me.
I squint, I can see my house from here.
Grab it.
Grab the thing.
Grab the little silly...
Grab the silly hand!
The gummy hand!
Loving the live mint reaction box.
Look, I didn't want to just be floating in mid-air, okay?
Finally.
Now I can get back to class.
Wait, what's that?
Oh, I got the stretchy hand.
That'll teach Dylan not to mess with me.
I got a stretchy hand.
But if it's so distracting, I'll get rid of it.
You certainly took your time, Oswald.
Sorry, Mrs. Meacham.
I really needed that break.
Oh, you couldn't say that the principal needed help too?
Oswald's falling asleep.
I'll see you tomorrow, class.
Make sure you're writing your essays.
Where did all these children come from?
I think the second day of school was even harder than the first.
Huh?
Is it lunchtime yet?
Play anything good recently?
I just got this new horror game.
What's scary is how it'll rot your brain.
Oh, thanks, Mrs. Meacham.
Do you ever feel like there's something you have to do...
but you don't know...
if you have what it takes to do it?
Oh, Oswald.
I'm sure your essay will be great.
Chat, I love this.
Mint, should I delete it?
Shut up!
Oh, right.
Yeah, my essay.
Oh, gosh.
Kiss of Iodine.
Maybe I should make some coffee.
What do the kids got to say?
What are the...
What's up, my fellow...
Oh, my gosh, we're wearing, like, the same T-shirt.
Dylan keeps trying to jump out from behind the lockers to scare me.
How does he get behind there?
Can't scare me if I see it coming.
Right?
Why did that...
Oh, God!
Oh, my God.
I was gonna say, why did the door open by itself?
Like, it was beckoning me.
It was inviting me in.
Did you hear?
We're dissecting frogs tomorrow.
It'll be so gross.
But also so cool.
Bring Your Own Blood is such a fun game.
What?
It has super cool graphics and gameplay.
Bring Your Own Blood.
Okay.
Not frog, but...
Yeah, I'm getting dissected.
Yeah, I haven't been touched like that since...
1987.
Oh, 19...
Wait, what was that?
Nothing.
Oh, wait.
What was the first one?
The New Modern Encyclopedia Volume 3.
From 1965.
Wow, modern.
Old frog.
Yeah, but I know some new tricks.
The frog of 87.
Is he gonna pop out?
Outside of some smelly gym clothes?
Stop.
Dylan.
Oh, why are you in here?
They won't let me do my synchronized water balloon fight performance.
Oh, yeah.
Apparently, the school doesn't have the budget for that many water balloons.
No.
Ugh.
How many did you ask for?
2,000.
I really like the thin reddish line inside the box, too.
Is that serious?
Pirate 505?
I think there's a bit, but it's supposed to be brown.
It's not supposed to be red.
That does sound like a bit much.
Well, it was originally 4,000.
So, I thought I was cutting him a deal.
Okay.
Let's see.
Look, she looks like she's gonna cry.
She looks so upset.
Oh, never mind.
She's over it.
She's over it, guys.
Anything else out here?
Some b-ball?
Shooting hoops now?
Come on.
There's nothing else in that backpack that I could use.
What about the water bottle?
What if Suzy from class three used it?
The water bottle?
Oh, that's a good one.
The volleyball team passed the preliminaries for the tournament.
Keep protecting your smile, your royal hotness.
What are you, Fuwamoka?
You're protecting my smile?
Nice.
Sounds like you guys really served up a win.
Stuffed stupid shark.
Thanks for the 5.50.
Haha.
And you really dished out a cheesy dad joke.
I learned from the best.
Okay.
Springtrap knows all the jokes.
Oh.
There's no bullies this time.
Oh my gosh.
This is cool.
Like, the windows are broken and everything.
Let's see.
Objective is to go home, but what if we go to the library?
Mr. McMayo, thanks for four months!
Has it really been like four months since I've come back?
Wait.
What is that?
Hold on.
There's something outside the window.
Never mind.
It was just a bird.
I was like, what is that?
What is that?
I was at the window.
It was just a bird.
My bad.
Can't go inside.
Can't go behind.
This game is like a little bit linear.
Any more questions?
Any more batteries?
Nope.
Okay.
Congrats on four months.
Thanks!
Linear is not bad.
No, no.
I'm not saying it in a bad way.
Okay.
Oh gosh.
Oh, you guys.
Tonight is gonna be...
Okay.
But after we get out tonight, with the...
Through the window, with the ladder, how else is there to get...
Why don't we just use the front door, Oswald?
All right.
I think there was a VTuber fan NPC in the school today.
Wait, really?
Oh, no!
Down at the pizzeria!
Hold on, hold on.
Four month Minto.
Crazy.
Let me out!
Let me leave!
In the school...
It isn't locked at night.
The door?
Yeah, but just unlock it from the inside.
Are you the VTuber fan?
Oh, the water balloon fight.
She looks so over it.
She looks so over it!
I think I talked with everybody, though.
I'm not gonna lie.
Dylan...
This guy...
Dissecting frogs...
Bring your own blood...
The gamer student...
He sounds like he'd be a VTuber fan.
Wait!
There's a VTuber fan, though?
That's so funny.
I just realized what you said.
How do you know he's a VTuber fan?
Does he say?
I like VTubers.
What about you?
I think I saw it.
There is, but he spawns randomly.
His name is VTuber fan!
Shut up.
He likes a certain shark girl.
Shut up!
No way.
Oops.
Oh!
Maybe him.
Oh.
Normally, I'm excited about leaving school and heading home.
Today, I'm dreading it.
Wait.
Hold on.
Oh, this is the science kid.
VTuber fan!
If you can hear me!
Say bow-wow!
Oh, what about you?
VTuber fan!
Nope.
Talking about Dylan.
If you are VTuber fan!
Say!
Why did I just get censored?
Fucking Patriots, man.
Him!
Oh, no.
It's the gamer student again.
Why is he talking about eating bugs?
Wait.
Who is she?
Hold on.
Okay.
I think I give up.
Oh, this is the volleyball girl.
That's right.
I like how kids just go into the principal's office.
Like, it's no big deal.
Okay.
I give up.
I believe you, though.
So, I believe that there is a VTuberFan in this school.
Probably.
Neil, you're the observant student.
I don't think he's gonna show.
One more try?
Where could he be?
1987?
No, it's modern day!
What are you talking about?
Purple striped shirt.
Okay, okay, okay.
But those students, like, walk around in here.
Go home, everybody!
Go home!
Went home to catch a stream?
Oh well.
This is science student, that's right.
Yeah, the gross, but cool.
Okay, let's go home.
Guys, I'm scared!
This one's gonna be hard.
This one's gonna be hard, right?
Oh gosh.
This one's gonna be hard.
Carrying a ladder makes a lot of noise!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Looks like it's roaming the house again.
Wait, roaming around the house again.
Time to find a way out of here.
Oh my god.
Okay.
It's all boarded up!
Do my homework!
My desk where I do my drawings.
Too stressed out to sketch something right now.
Has she tried the front door already?
Have you tried the front door?
No.
Actually, I don't think I have.
What is he gonna do?
Hammer the front door shut?
You can't.
Oh my gosh.
I can't read your name.
But thank you for the vibe gifted!
I hear him.
What do I have in my inventory?
No!
My inventory is still glitched!
No way!
This is so messed up.
My inventory is still glitched, you guys.
It doesn't show me everything.
Oh no!
Sticky and gross just like Dylan.
Um...
How many...
It doesn't say how many batteries I even have.
I hope it's not just the one.
Dad's wallet.
All the wooden balls.
Yeah, we got...
Okay, we have a glass.
Screwdriver!
Kid in the basement.
Screwdriver though!
I don't think it will help us much.
DM had the same problem?
Like girl DM?
Okay.
I don't know where he went.
I'm scared.
I'm scared you guys!
I don't hear anything though.
The way he crawls out is so funny.
I'm scared!
I don't hear anything.
Actually, I shouldn't have turned on the fan.
It makes it hard to hear.
I didn't hype myself up for a horror game!
He doesn't come into my room though, does he?
Don't think.
Just do.
Okay.
Thanks.
Thanks Maverick.
Oh my god.
What?
Why are the lights out?
Oh my god!
Just gonna go try the front door you guys.
Just run.
Oh!
Wait, it worked.
Oh
my god, it worked!
Yippee!
Holy cow!
It's so funny.
Lemonade.
Banana flavored soda.
A very yellow drink selection.
It's pizza themed.
Weird.
Where are the doors?
Oh, interesting.
Jeff, where are the doors?
You here to pick up a pizza?
No.
Just hanging out.
Oh.
Someone with the name...
Ima...
Lucer...
Called to place an order.
But they still haven't picked up their pizza.
Ima Lucer.
Must be new in town.
Lucer.
Jeff.
I don't think that's a real name.
Ima Lucer!
Lucer.
Ima Lucer.
Oh my god!
That's so mean!
Stay in school, kid.
Jeff.
Jeff, what happened to the doors?
What happened to the doors?
Jeff isn't a loser.
Jeff owns his own pizza place.
I think that's pretty respectable.
I'm not gonna lie.
Free refills for water only.
Oh, hello sir.
Oh,
hello.
The pizza used to be a lot better back in the old days.
Pizza fan!
Though I have to admit, ever since Jeff took over, it got a lot cheaper.
Quantity over quality, I guess.
His own failing pizza place.
Okay, whoa, whoa, whoa.
We're not judging.
Right!
I mean, sure, it was much better back in its heyday, but...
He still bought a business.
And he owns it, right?
Yeah.
Anything back here?
I forgot we can go in here and stuff still.
Anything in here?
Batteries?
Looked like the games Dad always talked about.
No.
Let's just turn it off and leave.
Oh my gosh, I can't see anything.
Can't see anything.
Doesn't help that I also have like a glare on my screen from like...
the window.
This kid could use some Minto to brighten his day.
What are you talking about?
Can we go in here?
Oh my god!
Wait, we can!
A battery!
Let's go.
How many batteries do I have?
Jeff makes the pizza here all by himself.
Guess he can't afford to hire more staff.
It's so sad.
This is a huge freezer.
Don't want to get locked inside.
Oh, that's right.
Oh, I got a power supply.
Okay.
Isn't there a room here?
Why can't we go in here?
Oh, it's sealed off.
But also!
In the past, there was like all the kids' bodies in there and stuff.
Let's see if it says how many batteries I have.
Nope.
Doesn't say at all.
Yeah, the party room.
Yeah, there was like a bunch of bodies and stuff.
Spooky freaky.
Would be fun to play.
Okay.
We got some more stuff so we can fix some more machines.
Not this one.
I hate this machine.
I'm never gonna fix that one.
Power supply?
Nice.
What's this game?
Let's go gambling!
Deliver the pizza.
Pizza time!
What do you mean game over?
What did I do?
What?
Where do you want me to go?
Huh?
The correct person first?
Excuse you.
How do I know which one is the right one?
How do I know which one is the correct one first?
Oh, oops.
Frogbert would love this.
Nah.
You ran into the people with your second tooth.
Oh, I did?
Wait, hold on.
Let's see.
Are you sure?
Oh.
What?
Oh, I think I'm pressing too many times.
Okay, I see.
I see.
Okay.
Hold on.
Okay, I get why I'm running.
Okay, I understand now.
I understand.
I press like... I kind of spam, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Whoa, this map is hard.
Okay.
Nice.
Nice and nice and nice.
This one is hard though.
I got the hard map.
I think.
Okay.
I never played Frogger as a kid because...
So I had a friend who...
Oh my god, this one is hard.
Who would invite me over to play games with him.
And he would be the only one to play them.
And he wouldn't let me play them.
He would...
He would be like, let's play Frogger!
And then played it all by himself.
And then just had me watch the entire time.
Maybe this is why I have trust issues with friends.
Because...
The kid was...
And he would always invite me over.
But he would not let me play the game!
And I'm like, come on man!
Like...
This is not...
Like I get Frogger is not supposed to be a multiplayer game, right?
But like, at least give me a chance to play!
Oh my god.
I'm killing it, you guys.
I'm killing it.
Just like the kids.
Just like William Afton killed those...
KIDS!
There's too many pizzas to deliver!
Oh my god.
This is no...
This is just...
This is just no!
Okay, okay, okay.
When's my turn to play for bugs?
No!
Oh, I almost ran out of time.
Almost ran out of time.
Oh my god.
Let's try and get the harder one first.
Okay, okay.
Nice!
You guys!
Yeah!
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
My fingers are starting to hurt.
My fingers are starting to hurt, you guys.
I think I'm gonna be...
Oh!
There we go.
Oof!
It's okay!
That was good enough.
Oh, what did we get?
Road Crossing!
Okay, nice.
Hi Vin!
Thanks for the $20!
Thank you!
So yeah, that's why I've never played Frogger before.
Because I didn't own it, and the one friend that I had that owned it did not let me play it.
Did she win?
Yeah.
I think I did.
I got the prize.
Oh my gosh, though.
I forgot to look up...
I went to bed after... I did a membership stream last night and I went to bed right afterwards.
And I forgot to read.
Some people were posting how to do the slide puzzle.
And I forgot to read it.
Sorry.
My throat is really killing me today.
You can do it?
You think so?
Thank you!
Thanks for the $10!
Thank you, thank you.
It's okay, I'll get out from under your desk.
Don't say that, because if I get it myself people are gonna be like, Oh, it was the fairy under her desk that solved the puzzle.
Not her.
Oh my...
They're not gonna...
You guys won't believe that it's me!
It was your idea, though.
I know.
I should've never said anything about it.
I'm gonna eat my other...
While I contemplate whether I want to...
Okay, it's not bad.
It's not so bad.
The company secret is out.
Oh my god.
What have we played?
Twitch plays Pokemon?
Chat plays slide puzzle.
I only listen to what you guys say.
Open up Discord again.
Make Pataris open up.
Oh no!
The super chat is from...
PLB?
Sunsheet music?
What?
All right, guys.
Solve it.
First down.
A...
Press Alt-F4.
Down, right, right.
Right...
Right.
Up.
Left.
There is no right!
I was listening to you!
I give up.
Today, we will solve it.
Mark my words!
What's in here?
Did I go in here before?
Oh, this is where...
Why did they take the phone out?
Hello?
The fairy under your desk isn't very smart.
Some days, it's a fairy.
Some days...
I don't know.
It could be like a little... something.
A groundhog.
I don't know.
Johnny!
Thanks for the 10 gifts!
What is it?
Oh, super old TVs.
I still haven't been able to go into the security room.
At all.
In any... in even the past or the present.
So maybe we'll go into the security room today.
Or maybe that's the last one because...
Well, we've gone everywhere else.
No, probably we go into security and...
This is what?
Night 3?
Go into security room and then we also have to probably go into the party room?
I bet dad is probably in the party room, right?
Oh my gosh, should we go in there now?
Is his like body in there?
Do we know about Quiet AKA Stephanie Joosten?
There's a YouTube channel.
Oh yeah, I did know!
Wait.
Sorry.
Correction.
I knew she was streaming.
Someone told me that she was streaming Metal Gear.
I don't want to freak her out or anything though.
Hehehe.
That thing came from the arcade last time.
Maybe it's keeping dad there.
Chip 2.
I hear the phone ringing.
Oh gosh.
I went in here with such gusto and now I'm afraid.
Hehehe.
The easiest way...
might actually be...
going to...
the basement...
and taking the vent...
to the party hallway.
I believe.
Can I have some of your gusto?
It's like...
It's a...
I haven't... I actually haven't been to a family restaurant yet.
I haven't been out very much, I'll be honest, in Japan.
Like I went to one maid cafe.
Only one!
And it wasn't even like a real maid cafe.
Like...
Well, no.
That's a lie.
It wasn't your traditional maid cafe.
It was just like a cafe with maids.
So I'm just like...
I...
I've been pre...
Kind of like...
Just holed up in my hotel room a lot.
But also since I...
Since I didn't have my um...
Wallet...
I was scared to do anything.
Okay.
We're gonna drive to the basement strat.
I feel like other stuff is gonna be blocked.
You know?
Oh, but the...
The phone...
Wait, the phone is in the storage, right?
Okay, let's go try and get the phone.
I don't hear anyone.
It's in here, right?
I'm scared!
Oh, a coin.
Oh my god.
I just heard something.
I just heard a door open.
Oh, no, no.
That's a freezer.
That is...
Hello?
Well...
If you are still listening...
Wait, what's that picture?
There are certain things they don't tell you when you sign up.
The animatronic...
Picture of my family on vacation.
And if they see a person...
Dad normally carries this on him.
Oh my god.
That scared me.
There are some of those backstage...
Go, go, go.
Or you haven't checked them out already.
Anyway...
Oh, shit, shit, shit, shit, shit, shit!
Ah!
Did you see me?
Did you see me?!
Ha!
Where am I?
Is that the door to the kitchen or the ball pit?
OK.
Chica just went to the kitchen, right?
So, this door I'm in front of is the ball pit.
I think.
Wait.
Wait, is he actually gone?
I'm just gonna run a little bit away.
Real quick.
Hold on.
Let's get our bearings real quick.
So, if I go to the party hallway, I can go up into the arcade...
Sorry, phone guy.
I totally interrupted that guy.
Wait, I hear him.
Never mind.
I hear him.
So yeah, we'll go through this door to the party hallway.
I hear him!
Oh, he's scaring me.
Oh, he makes such creepy noises.
Oh my god, it looks like my body became... I became Springtrap for a second.
Wait, did he see me?
Uh oh.
I don't know what just happened.
What just happened?
Oh, it was Chica!
Wait, she just went through the hall!
Oh no!
Oh my gosh.
She just went into the arcade!
No!
Oh no!
I don't know which door Springtrap went through!
I should have been looking.
I should have looked.
At least Chica... Okay, so Chica alerts Springtrap.
But she doesn't, like, grab you, it seems.
Which isn't so bad, as long as there's a place to hide, right?
But we can't go into the arcade because Chica just went in there.
Oh, oh, here she comes, here she comes.
Oh, never mind.
What the... How did you... When you went to the... Maybe he went in a circle.
Maybe.
I think.
He must have gone in a circle, I guess.
That is not Chica.
Where is Chica?
Okay, bye.
Do you think it's fine to go in there?
Even if she's in the arcade?
Do you think it's fine to... I don't actually know if this pauses the game either, so it kind of freaks me out.
But the arcade has nowhere to hide.
The storage has... Freddy?
So let's go maybe in there.
Where does this vent go to?
Oh, it goes to the entrance.
Okay.
Maybe I go to the entrance.
Wait, I don't know.
But she's still in here.
Assuming.
I'm assuming she's still in there.
I can't hear her anymore.
Oh my god, the sound.
Is that a photo?
This is my school picture from last year.
Dad always keeps this on him.
Oh my god.
Get in there.
That's where Chica is.
Oh my god.
Rhyme Snap!
What are you doing?
Thanks for the time, Gilton.
Look at her... look at her stalking.
Go away.
Why are you camping?
Get out of here.
Let's eat.
No, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no.
Chica, Chica, Chica.
Go downstairs, please.
Chica!
Hello?
Oh my god.
The door is...
Who are you?
What?
Are things that are happening in the past affecting the present?
Like, so this endoskeleton broke the doors and that's why the doors disappeared in the present?
But like, just fix them.
It's Benny Big Bear.
Okay, guys.
We're just gonna make a run for it.
Hopefully no one's in here.
The door is locked.
I need to find another way.
Okay.
Oh, I do have to go through the party hallway then probably.
No!
Beekeeper, welcome to membership.
And Rokkimei, welcome to membership.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you, thank you.
Dang it.
Oh.
Someone's coming.
I think.
I hear them.
I can't tell where they are.
I can...
They're here!
Yeah, get out of here.
Wait, he's going in security.
Which, there's nothing else in there that we know of currently.
Oh my god.
No, no, no.
Please hide.
Please.
Hide.
I don't think I hear anything.
I think we can go in.
Wait.
The door is locked!
Here too!
Wait.
What other way is there to get in?
Do I maybe go to the entrance after all and maybe move the exoskeleton?
Hmm.
He is the security guard.
No!
Okay, let's go back to storage, I guess.
It's kind of icky.
Is there a vent?
I don't think so.
Does security have anything of importance?
The only thing I know about security is we have not been in security.
So it's the only place that we haven't been yet.
Okay.
Oh.
Who am I hearing?
Someone...
Where are they?
Oh!
The door is clearly not locked!
I don't think animatronics have special keys now, do they?
Oh my god.
Oh my good.
I don't know which door he went through.
I don't know if he is in there or if he went down.
Let's just go for it.
Be brave.
Woah!
Woah woah woah.
What was that shiny?
Wait wait wait wait.
Did you see that shiny up there?
Stretching hand?
There's something shiny in there.
If only I could...
Wait a second.
My sticky hand!
I got a key.
Oh my god.
Oswald, please.
Please.
Sorry, I guess you guys couldn't see it because the chat was blocking it a little bit probably.
But good stuff.
Let's just go for it.
That doesn't seem very good.
Find something to lure the rabbit out.
That was close!
Maybe if I knew more about that thing, I could somehow lure it away.
Okay, let's read the diary again.
Our special diary.
Wherever it is.
Oh my god, my mom is hot!
Dad took this photo of me and mom on our last beach trip.
Dad and I got so sunburned that mom kept calling us a pair of lobsters.
We should have reapplied Sunday.
But dad and I were too busy swimming to remember.
Hot mama!
Not sure how mom puts up with us sometimes.
Dad always takes a photo of me on the first day of school.
It's kind of embarrassing.
But I think it makes him happy.
He wasn't able to take a photo on my first day.
I was just about to say he didn't take a photo this year.
He wasn't able to take a photo on my first day this year.
Aww.
It's so sad.
One out of five.
Two out of five.
Three out of five.
So we have three out of five things.
What am I looking for?
Oh, the sketchbook.
That's right.
So this has information about the different animatronics.
So we knew the things about the no eating around Chica.
She could smell my food.
And we also brought her a pizza.
Do not attempt to play Bonnie's guitar.
Bonnie's guitar.
Where was that?
In the basement?
I think?
Any voice box malfunctions must be reported to upper management.
Adjusted hug fractured a kid's back again.
Yeah, that's what I meant.
Backstage, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's where his guitar was.
By night five, we're gonna have to be dealing with all three of these...
Or all of these guys, aren't we?
The three of them, plus Springtrap, plus this little...
cupcake monster.
Okay.
I guess I have to go to the backstage.
Was there anywhere to hide back there?
Oh, I think actually...
I think there was... Oh yeah, the vent.
Oh no, that's in the basement.
Oh shoot.
The double doors to the arcade are destroyed.
Oswald, you created a time paradox!
You can't go changing the future like that!
Oswald the Ocelot.
Okay.
I just have to be brave.
I'm not very brave!
Where are we?
We're in storage.
We have to get pretty far to get backstage.
Alright, let's go.
I don't think I hear anything.
Oh, that's a scream?
Oh my god!
Why?
Am I good?
No, I'm not good.
Get out of here.
Oh my god.
Get out of here!
Why are you both here?
Oh, come on.
This is so unfair.
And he's coming back, I think.
Okay.
Does he go into the kitchen?
I think this is my chance.
Oh
no.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Where does this lead again to?
Oh, so we lure him and then we take this.
Okay, easy peasy.
Okay, so we'll activate the guitar.
Run in here.
Take the vent.
Leave.
Too dark to see.
Yeah, it's really dark.
But it's okay because I know where the vent is.
Let's go.
Please don't be in here.
There we go.
This is that blue rabbit's guitar.
But the strings are broken.
Oh, I bet I can find some old ones in the garage?
Find something to fix the guitar.
The...
My garage at home?
Oh, garbage!
Thank you for the 50 gifted.
Thank you.
Garbage.
So maybe I do go to the present then.
After all.
My Yoshi can't read.
Stop making fun of me!
I think you need that coffee.
I think so too.
Good golly.
Okay.
To the garbage.
Not the garage.
I was like, I don't think...
I was like, we have a basement.
I don't think we have a garage.
Everything good?
Oh, hey Jeff.
There aren't some old guitar strings lying around here somewhere, are there?
My Kamiyoshi can't read, but she's cute.
So it's okay.
Guitar strings?
There could have been when I bought this place.
But I just had about everything trashed.
This place used to be one of those germ infested kitty pizza places with that dumb robot band.
You mean animatronics?
Any who?
Never mind.
Okay, Jeff.
You told us to stay in school.
I think you need to take your own advice.
Let's go to the mill.
That looks like some guitar strings.
Who knew Oswald the ocelot...
Oh my god, this kid.
Was also Oswald the raccoon.
This will definitely make headlines in school.
Why do you laugh like that, you freak?
What's he doing here?
Whatever.
I can worry about him.
I can't worry about him right now.
I need to get back.
Okay.
That spooked me good though.
That actually got me.
I think I might make coffee for real.
Is it okay if I make it?
Actually?
Shouldn't take too long.
It's one of those, like, espresso machines.
You know that, like, coffee machine?
Like, how hotels have those in their rooms.
My throat has just been killing me.
I woke up with, like, a stuffy nose.
I'm wondering if me, like, going out in the heat and sweating all day and then coming into a cold room or, like, you know, going...
It's basically me going hot, cold, hot, cold, hot, cold because I'll, like, go into a cafe or something.
And I'll be covered in sweat.
And then...
You know, stuff like that.
Can I get a quick happy birthday from my community?
Sunchips!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Sunchips.
Happy birthday!
Yeah, I don't know.
It's just been, like, my nose or my throat right now.
My nose is a little bit stuffed, but...
Okay.
I'm going to make some coffee real quick before we go back into the past.
Yes, yes.
Oh, I'm going to the wrong place.
Okay.
Give me, like, two minutes to make some coffee.
We're back.
One minute's passed.
Oh, my gosh.
She hates us.
What are you...
I said two minutes.
Okay.
Oh, my gosh.
So, I also went to the bathroom while it was...
While it was brewing.
And I had, like...
I was, like, oh, my gosh.
Did I forget to mute?
You'll come back.
Thank you.
I got my coffee.
Can you hear it?
Did you wash your hands?
Of course.
Hey, I always wash my hands.
Unfortunately, it did mute.
Unfortunately.
I don't think you would even be able to hear anything.
Maybe just the toilet flushing.
Probably.
Oh, my gosh.
This tastes so good.
Ew.
Sometimes I'm...
Sometimes I'm just not in a coffee mood.
But lately I have been.
Just wanting like creamy and all.
What if by accident you just forgot?
Shut up.
Mint is into Ace Attorney?
Yeah!
I love Ace Attorney!
Is it face coffee?
No, actually I've never had face coffee.
Is it actually any good?
Thanks for being a goober, Mint!
You're one in a million and if you were a booger in a stuffy nose, I'd pick you first.
May a thousand wet cat noses calm your soul.
Thanks?
No.
I tried Leah coffee, not bad.
But I make mine really sweet.
I see, I see.
There's a Leah brew.
Maybe I'll have to get that.
Is it like a light brew or a dark brew though?
I got a haunted postcard today!
It was beautiful!
Yay!
I'm so glad that they're showing up at people's places now.
No more.
Stop!
Stop replying to that super chat!
The worst feature YouTube has ever implemented!
Stop!
You freaks!
You're all freaks!
You're all freaks, you're all freaks!
Okay, here we go.
What is a+.1?
Wait, hold on, I missed it.
Why are we plus one-ing?
Oh, plus one, plus one.
For the cat?
Or for what?
For the booger?
I don't know.
Uh oh, I think I just broke my chat.
Hold on, I gotta refresh.
Give me a second, guys.
Oh, I got a chat summary!
Viewers in the chat are making various comments about a name, finding the chat entertaining, and joking about the chat reflecting the streamer's personality.
What's that?
Outlander.
Okay, so we go backstage.
Okay, let's just do it.
Let's just do it.
Fix the guitar.
I'm scared.
Do you think he's gonna come in here?
Probably won't sound good, but at least it works.
Wait.
Oh my god.
Wait, where do I go?
I think he's coming.
For real?
Wait, I thought we were gonna like... Wait, this is going against everything that I thought we were going to do.
Wait.
So do I bring the guitars to him?
Or do I... Where do I play it?
Huh?
Oh my gosh.
What is happening?
Plus two cat noses.
Thank you.
Where do I put... lure the rabbit out?
Is it that cord?
Oh, the stage.
Yes, it's the cord on the stage, isn't it?
I knew it.
Okay, okay, okay.
We'll go back.
I thought we were playing... I don't know.
I don't know, man.
I don't know.
Oh, he's in here.
Okay, that's good though.
That's good actually.
That's good.
Move back.
Okay, so we know he's in here.
So we can leave here.
And we can go...
here.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, freaks.
Let's jam.
Oh my god, I'm scared.
Oh, don't!
W.
A.
Uh-oh.
I need to get out of here.
Run, run, run!
Look for a place to hide.
Oh my god.
Sorry.
Okay, okay, okay.
He came really fast.
Why didn't you leave sooner?
Space,
space, space, space!
I don't think I spaced hard enough, you guys.
Dang it!
Oh, I thought it was just like a quick time, you know?
I didn't realize it was a spammy one.
Wait, how far back do I have to go?
Oh.
Okay, so I have the guitar.
I hear him though.
I hear him.
I'm gonna have to come back and hide...
in here.
Let's do what we did before.
Maybe he'll go back to this room.
Oh, he is in this room!
Okay, nice, nice, nice.
Yeah.
It's the quick time versus the spamming ones.
I don't...
Oh my gosh, please.
Oswald.
I didn't get it right.
That's okay.
Like I pressed it and then it wasn't...
I wasn't spamming it.
It's my bad.
Okay, freaks.
Let's jam!
W.
S?
D.
Okay.
Get out of here!
Oh my god, please.
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
Please, run, run, run, run, run.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Okay, this part is timed.
This part is scripted.
Nice.
Okay.
All right, here we go.
All right.
I'm already...
I'm pre-spamming.
Nice.
Yeah.
I'll have to follow the vents.
Oh.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Oh my...
Okay.
Yikes.
That was close.
Gotta get back to the arcade.
Okay.
Um.
Can I hide under this table?
No.
I can only hide under this table.
Okay.
Why did we climb out of that one?
Wait.
Why didn't you climb out of the one closer to the door, you stupid idiot?
Oswald, use your brain!
I think we're okay.
Where's my...
Oh my god.
It's bonking my friend.
Chip!
Are you alive?
He's got brain damage.
Thanks.
I don't know what that...
Thank me later.
Was there a grown-up with you?
No.
Have you seen Mike?
I found him.
He's safe now.
Okay.
Oh.
Come on, man.
We gotta split.
No.
I...
Ah!
Freddy!
Oh my god.
Ah!
Get out of here!
Hide in here!
Oh, shoot.
I just realized the objective was to escape.
I'm an idiot.
Run, run, run, run, run!
To the ball pit!
Oh, shoot.
Ah!
Hoor!
Day four!
Uh-oh.
Was it looking a little more corrupted than usual?
Ah.
Off to school.
No idea how I'll make it through the day.
I barely slept.
Let's pet the cat.
This little baby.
Who is that bunny I see?
Staring straight back at me.
There's a lot of clothes in there.
I check every time.
And the pictures.
Some of them... some of the dialogues change.
Some of them don't.
Oh, Mom?
Mom?
Where's my lunch, Mom?
Why was it making that sound?
These dusty old boxes have been down here for as long as I can remember.
The thought of holding a knife or whatever.
Yeah.
Huh.
Why is it laughing?
Wait, is he...
Mom?
Morning, Oz.
Double shift today and tomorrow.
Boo.
Be safe getting to school.
Is he patrolling?
Oh, he's patrolling, isn't he?
No.
He's not.
He's not, because it's not allowing me to hide.
He's probably waiting for me.
At the... at the front door.
Right?
No?
Okay.
Do I just go?
Oh my god, it's really creepy!
Where is he?!
Oh my gosh, it's so scary!
Oh, I should go to school.
Oh, okay.
Okay, I'm leaving!
Bye, Springtrap Dad!
That was so creepy!
He's Spring Dad.
Spring Dad.
The animatronic characters here get a bit quirky at night.
Go to class.
What's going on?
Why is everything so different?
It's smoky.
It's foggy.
Oh, okay, there are people here!
Hello, fellows.
Students?
Principal?
Anybody here?
No?
Nothing?
Okay.
Silent Hill now.
How do you do, fellow kids?
Hoops?
Now?
Come on!
That's how I would always remember how to spell principal.
Because it's a principal.
Except that's a big ol' lie.
They don't do anything for you.
Let's see.
Ooh, what are you guys talking about?
Oh.
I can't join in on their conversation.
Okay, what about you?
Nobody will talk to me!
Hello?
Oh no!
It's because they all think I'm a raccoon!
Hey, look, it's Oswald the raccoon!
I'm surprised he's not still out digging in the dumps.
Yeah, he probably smells right at home there.
Oh my god!
What's the matter, Snoswald?
Looks like you're ready to puke.
Maybe all that trash has made him sick.
Maybe he's finally losing it.
Mr. Crab's last finesse.
Oh my god!
Ossie!
Oh no!
I gotta get out of here!
Go to the ball pit?
Already?
I'm going to the ball pit so soon!
Why am I craving the ball pit?
He craves the pit.
What if I go to the library?
Just get a good book to read.
What do you mean each spot has its own... wait, what is this?
Hey firecracker kid.
Ha, still dig that name.
You still want to trade for one?
Yeah, I have this.
Not the sticky hand.
We have the Freddy mask.
Animatronics aren't as scary when they're Fortnite dancing.
Oh nice, you got yourself a trade.
Awesome.
Thanks.
Pleasure doing business with you.
I got... I got firecrackers!
Uh, not... what?
Did he just stick that mask in his pants?
Alright, let's go to the pit now.
The Pizzeria.
Go to the ball pit.
Jeff?
Don't have the right item.
There's still items I'm missing.
Oh wait, what's this one?
I have it.
What could it be?
Oh, the balls?
That's all I needed?
Was the balls?
Let's go.
Oh no.
Oh wait.
Wait.
Oh no.
I'll be honest, I'm actually pretty good at this game.
I'm actually pretty good at this game when I actually play it, you know?
How do you get it in the 50?
I think I'm off a little bit.
Thanks Freddy!
How do I get out?
Exit.
Oh, E to exit.
Why is the music so...
Complete all arcade games!
Oh!
Okay, nice!
So, what about this one then?
I don't have the right item for this cabinet.
This one wasn't one either?
Or there was... I thought one other one.
I guess this one doesn't matter.
We don't care about it at all.
Have the voucher.
And this one...
Busted and broken.
Bummer.
They were fun to play.
Hmm...
Possessing the skee-ball machine to drive up your score does not count as being good.
No!
I promise!
I am actually pretty good at it when I play on the arcades, for real.
Guys, this might be my last opportunity to play it.
This might be my last opportunity.
The
process...
It's not that hard.
You underestimate...
You underestimate how... how difficult slide puzzles are for me!
Hold on, I'm gonna go look up that one.
That one comment.
David, it was yours, right?
Hold on.
I'm gonna go look it up.
And see what you said.
And how well you described it.
Let's see.
Um.
I see it, I see it, I see it.
Okay.
Instead of thinking about getting a piece in a particular spot, think about everything in loops.
See, that's what makes it more difficult for me.
You have to change the controller port too.
In a 3x3 puzzle, there's only nine possible loops.
Oh gosh.
Okay, I'm already getting confused.
Okay.
You're doing your best... to help me.
No matter how many you slide in a loop, it'll stay the same.
To make any changes in the puzzle, you need to switch between loops.
Oh gosh.
Oh god.
I'm already confused.
You explained it so nicely, David!
And I'm dumb!
I'm sorry!
You're...
You wasted your time!
I'm stupid!
Okay, hold on.
I don't want the timer to go up needlessly, you know?
Okay.
Oh
gosh, I don't know.
I hate slide pipes!
I hate them!
With a passion!
Just brute force it!
I'm gonna start crying, you guys.
That's it?
You got it?
I do?
Wait, I almost have it.
What do you mean?
What do you mean I had it?
I'm so confused.
I'm a possessor PC.
Do it, please.
You're in the right direction.
I'm trying to mathematize a little bit.
Oh gosh, oh gosh.
But how then do I get this...
It's so confusing!
It doesn't make any sense to me!
The top row and left column.
I know people told me that before, but I don't...
That's the problem.
I don't even know how to solve the top row and the left column.
Oh my gosh.
I hate this.
It was my fault at explaining.
No!
What are you talking about?
You explained it wonderfully!
I just don't know or understand numbers.
No!
Okay.
If you solve the top row...
But how do I get him in there?
How do I smush him in there?
Whiskers?
Huh?
What's whiskers?
This?
What's a whiskers?
How do I get him in there?
I have to get...
I have to get this in front of...
I don't understand how to...
I don't understand...
Oh...
How
do I make him... get this in...
God,
I love the ear.
Yeah, I know.
I need the ear.
Hold on.
Right?
Because when I do this...
It'll be...
Wait, does it...
Wait, I can't... I can't remember.
Comito, put that brain into maximum overdrive.
I can't remember.
Wait, I can't remember if...
If this needs to be... If I do it now...
Wait...
Like that?
Or if it's backward.
I can't remember.
I guess we'll figure it out.
Once we get here.
Right?
Oh, wait.
She's cooking.
I'm going to have a heart attack.
We failed our youth.
Hey, just because I didn't do...
Don't be mean, okay?
Don't be mean.
I've never understood these.
Yeah, we need a hole to rotate.
I'm closing chat because you guys stress me out.
I don't want to see mean comments.
I don't...
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
I think I... Oh, wait.
Let's go the other way, maybe.
Actually, I can't tell if I just messed it up or not.
But you know what?
Whatever.
No!
Wait.
Oh my god, we're so close!
I can see his face.
Now, does it need to be...
No, I messed it up again.
I think.
Okay, now...
No, I need the ear behind the thing.
I need the ear behind this piece.
Right here.
This one.
The one I'm highlighting.
How do I get it in front?
There.
Okay.
Close enough.
Okay, okay, okay.
I hope there's not like a...
You need to solve it by this time.
You know?
That would be really unfortunate.
This is the bottom left, right?
I think.
Like there.
And I think that's where that goes.
Oh.
No.
Okay.
So now I should solve the left side, right?
Probably.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh!
We're so close!
Oh
my gosh!
I just have it in the rungs of butt!
Wait.
It wasn't worth it.
Slidy Pieces Puzzle.
I got ten tickets for that.
Yeah!
We did it!
Oh my gosh.
G-man, thanks for the ten gifted.
McFerrick, thanks for the five gifted!
Never doubted for a second.
Congrats, Minto Gaming.
Thank you.
Alright.
Go to the ball pit.
Is there anything else?
Like...
No, I guess there wouldn't be any.
GG.
Ducky, thanks for the five gifted!
Oh, sure!
Thank you for the fifty gifted!
Oh!
Hey, kid.
Shouldn't you be in school?
Uh...
Not today!
Puzzle solving tax.
Okay.
You know where to find me.
Oh.
Oh, so he is here.
Okay.
Now's my chance to get a head start.
Funds for the fairy under the desk.
Tell them they did a good job.
Wait.
Oh, my bad.
I didn't mean to go up here.
Um...
I wanted to go talk to Jeff again.
Good job, fairy.
You can eat today.
Here to pick up a pizza?
No, just hanging out.
Oh, okay.
Oh my gosh.
I feel so fulfilled.
I feel...
Oh, I feel so fulfilled.
Back to the ball pit.
How is Springtrap in more than one place?
One...
How is he everywhere?
You gotta be kidding me.
How many kids do they trap here?
Objective.
Investigate the scream.
Okay.
We're going?
We're investigating the scream?
I'm scared.
What is...
Oh, my God.
I saw the hand.
I saw the hand but I...
wasn't sure.
I was like, oh, maybe that's an item I pick up.
Oh, my God.
I heard a door open though.
Oh.
There he is.
He's coming.
I got his achievement even for it.
Oh, hello.
He's here.
Hi Springtrap.
Where did the scream come from?
Maybe the front door?
Just go to the entrance and check.
Wait.
Who else am I hearing now?
That was Chica, wasn't it?
Hello Ms. Minto.
Hope you don't get spooked today.
Thank you.
Springtrap always comes back, but it's not specified at what time and place when.
So clearly, all places at all times.
I see.
I'm probably being overly cautious, but...
Being a little overly cautious.
What's that?
Is that a piece that I need?
He always...
Brings back.
Where did the scream come from?
The security maybe?
I guess we'll figure it out.
Hello!
Why don't you take care of the children that you are like...
Holding hostage and stuff instead of worrying about me?
I can't tell if like he's walking away if he'll notice me, you know what I mean?
I guess we'll check it out here.
Oh.
That was a thing that I needed.
Oh my god!
I'm such an idiot!
Why did I do that?!
What's wrong with me?
What's wrong with me, you guys?
I keep thinking that you can hide behind the Freddy Fazbear.
I keep thinking you can hide behind him.
But maybe that was good.
Maybe they'll all run that way.
Oh!
Okay.
I did it!
I didn't even know that...
Oh my god, there's so many puppets in there.
Uh-huh.
What's this?
Blah blah blah?
There's so many puppets in there.
Play some games in the arcade.
Okay.
Not every machine works, though.
This isn't livestream 2, Minto.
You can't hide behind the mascot cutouts.
Maybe that's what I'm thinking of.
Here!
They're close!
What?
Who?
The cameras.
What?
No, I can't.
The noise.
Wait, what do you mean?
Some batteries are in this locker.
Wait.
Objective, check the cameras.
Oh.
Oh!
No, no, wait.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, wait.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
No, it's becoming actual Freddy.
Oh my god.
No, no.
Wait, is my dad in here?
Oh my god.
It's becoming actual Freddy.
Five Nights at Freddy's.
Oh my god.
No, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Whoa.
They move really fast.
Oh my god.
That actually launched me out of my chair.
There's a balloon boy on the camera now.
Oh my gosh.
That launch, I literally flinched back in my chair so bad.
Follow me.
We have to get out of here.
No, I can't.
They're still out there.
I need to get them away from here.
Oh my gosh.
I flinched so badly.
Um, distract the creature.
So it's a creature in the entrance.
Gosh.
Is there an item under that kid?
It seems like there's something.
Oh, here.
My dad's wedding ring.
I need to get him back to mom.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
That should be 4 out of 5, right?
If I can find it.
Oh!
5 out of 5!
Okay, we're missing 4 out of 5.
I wish I could hide in the lockers.
I feel like you should be able to hide in the lockers, I'm just saying.
Okay, so here is... there's something in here?
In the entrance?
Is that what it is?
Why are the lights out in the arcade?
Oh, and in here too?
What is going on?
It's so scary!
Ball pit.
Security room.
Or... storage room.
Okay.
Wait, wait, wait.
Guys?
Guys, my game is glitched?
Oswald, where have you gone?
I can't move!
Oh my god, no way!
No, no, no!
Wait, let me check the camera.
Oh, I can't even check the cameras.
No way!
Did Freddy Fazbear just open that door?
And check the seat?
But I'm gone.
Because... wait.
Freddy just came in here to check on the situation?
No way!
Are you soft locked, son?
You literally...
Okay, so it probably will have me go back to the...
From here, I probably should be okay.
Distract the creature, right?
Probably?
Alright, let's go to the title screen.
Okay.
Everyone loves our pizza.
Especially Chica.
Okay, okay, okay.
We're back.
We're back, everyone.
And, uh... Oswald, come in!
Do you copy?
Oswald!
Okay.
I just want to look over this, just in case you get something for it.
You know what I mean?
Oh, my bad.
Okay, there we go.
Alrighty.
There's a fuse here.
So what do we do to distract the creature?
Is my thing...
Why don't we... Okay.
Other solution.
The kid climbs through the vent with us, and there's nothing here.
Better solution.
The kid just goes through the vent and leaves through the entrance.
Easy peasy.
I think.
Right?
Too big!
They're the same size as us!
Yeah, solution.
Just leave.
But I actually don't know what to do to distract the creature.
We need to get the creature away from the entrance?
Right?
I'm not quite sure.
Let's see.
If I do this...
Oh!
Return to the security room!
Oh, okay.
That was it?
Okay.
What?
No!
Where'd she go?
Oh my god.
I hate.
Do I check the cameras?
Okay.
Yeah.
Hello?
Are you in the ball pit?
Why not?
Wouldn't you want to be in the ball pit?
Not in storage.
Oh my god!
No!
Where are you taking our springtrap?
Into the kitchen?
Okay.
Where is it taking her?
Look for the kid.
Oh shoot.
Shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot.
Chica!
Let him cook!
Chica, go away!
This girl is just like...
Wah!
Oh!
Do I hear the phone ringing?
Am I crazy?
No, I think the phone is ringing.
Stop camping!
Seriously!
Stop camping, Chica!
This is messed up, actually.
Yeah, I hear the phone.
I don't know if I'll be able to get it, though.
Oh, come on!
Right as Chica leaves!
This is... this is unfair.
This is unfair.
Who else am I hearing?
Literally as she opened the door.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
I just heard them open the door.
I know she's in here.
Are you in the fridge?
Won't budge.
The lock looks pretty old, though.
I bet I can find something to smash it?
I need to get that girl out before she freezes.
Or is she in the oven?
I feel like I could get swallowed whole by the oven.
Okay, find a way to open the freezer.
What is this?
Wait.
25 cents for candy?
I could eat candy for the rest of my life!
Mom wouldn't like that, though.
Find a way to open the freezer.
Something to smash the freezer with.
I think we should... maybe leave.
And maybe I find something in my own time.
Like in the present.
Maybe.
Hmm.
But also, we got one more thing.
We got the ticket thing.
Here.
Was there a hammer in the arcade?
Oh, was there?
Because we have... we got this.
To fix the ticket counter.
Ohio... oh, whoops.
My bad.
No, no, no, no.
Get out of here.
This one.
We got...
Ohio, enjoy your welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Fix all arcade cabinets!
Yippee!
Okay.
Oh, hi, Jeff.
Hey, kid.
Been noticing you tinkering around with these old machines.
I don't mind, but... wait, did you fix all of them?
Where'd you learn to do that?
My dad.
He's pretty good with machines.
He repaired all the equipment at the mill when he worked there.
Sometimes he'd sneak me in during summer so I could watch.
Wow.
I don't really know what to say.
I've been letting this place go for quite a while now.
Maybe it's time I fixed things up around here, too.
Oh my gosh, Jeff is turning over a new leaf!
The red button in security was interactable.
Does that do anything?
Yes, it's an alarm.
It will... it will make a loud sound.
Yeah.
Thanks for your hard work, Oswald.
Here, take this.
Don't worry about the expiration date.
Oh, wow.
Thanks, Jeff.
It's...
75 cents off.
Least I could do for you.
What a deal.
Oh, I got a pizza coupon.
It's in my inventory.
It's actually in my... somewhere in here.
We have to find the 4 out of 5 also.
We have... just missing one more.
Where is it?
Where could it be?
This is so scuffed.
Where's my...
Where's... sketchbook?
Stretching...
Token, battery, tickets, phone...
It said it was in my inventory!
Why is your inventory blank?
Because it's... it's... it's glitched.
So I can't see anything.
Check the sketchbook, last page.
Oh, you think it's in there?
Oh, thank you.
Save 75 cents on large pizza.
Only pizza in town.
Jeff's Pizza.
Okay, okay.
Thank you.
Otherwise I would have been like, hello?
Excuse me?
Hello?
Oh wait, we have... we can now use it.
We have tickets.
89 of them?
Looks like I have enough for a prize voucher.
Nice.
And this does work now, right?
Voucher?
Looks like I got some sort of old game thing.
I can barely see the screen.
Who would have won something like this?
Handheld gaming device?
Prize voucher?
Okay, so 20 tickets is a prize voucher.
Let's just use all of them.
How many do I have left?
Nine, okay.
Got some sign of sticker.
Guess my sketchbook is as good as any place for it.
Oh, okay.
Wait, I want to see it.
Oh, your sketchbook now?
For you?
It's kind of cute.
I'll take it.
Do I need to play more games, you think?
Another sticker?
How many stickers are in this thing?
What's that one?
Oh, that one's so cute!
I love the Bonnie one!
I love that one!
That one's so cute.
Okay.
Voucher.
My third sticker.
I guess that makes me a collector now.
Oh, I'm sorry.
There's not a...
There's not an achievement for...
Oh my god, the Freddy one's so cute!
There's not an achievement for getting all the stickers.
It's kind of messed up.
Why isn't Foxy in this game, I wonder?
Boasts a 30-minute battery life on six batteries.
Tradable...
A tradable item.
Huh.
Okay, so we need to...
Is there anything else in here?
That rocket ship looks so cool.
Hmm.
We just keep doing the slide puzzle.
Which one's this one?
Oh, collect the hats.
I don't like this one.
Let's do another one.
Oh, sorry guys.
Ew.
Why does Chica look so creepy in the menu?
Rescue the children?
Oh, I hate this one too.
Never mind.
I don't want that one.
That one's scary.
That one stresses me out.
What's this one?
Hefton with...
Help please.
Oh, that's right!
Game over.
What's the highest you've seen someone get on this?
Oh, we got 11 tickets.
Okay, this one's good.
This one's good.
Because it's fast and it's easy.
You know?
20?
I think 15.
Without cheating?
Yeah, without cheating.
Legit.
Not breaking it.
16.
How the hell?
Okay.
Prize voucher.
Huh?
No more?
Wait, what?
Did I eat my voucher?
So can I not get any more?
Hold on.
Let's try...
It was help please.
There was this one again.
Don't even think about using auto fire.
Oh no.
I'm too weak today.
I can't be my best.
I'm too weak.
What else can we do?
What's this one again?
Deliver the pizza.
Oh!
This is the Frogger.
I hate that.
I wish I could just like hold it down sometimes.
This one's just...
This one is really just until how I want to go.
How long I want to go.
So maybe...
I won't get an optimal amount of...
tickets, you know?
Let's see how many we get.
I do like that there's the mini-games in this though, you know?
It's fun.
It's pretty fun.
I like it.
I don't want to go too far because I just want to get the tickets and go.
Does this one give tickets?
It should, right?
Wait, does this one not give tickets?
We'll find out.
I got...
only three tickets!
This game sucks!
Redeem it in the past for something, I think.
Maybe?
Oh no, I hate this one too.
Fast Food Invader.
Oh, oh, this one.
This one was kind of fun though.
Oh, but I hate that I have to continuously press space.
Like, I can't hold down space.
Which seems very inefficient, you know?
I don't know.
Don't even think about using auto-fire.
Oh, oopsie.
Sorry, I was reading chat.
How many?
Oh, I only got two tickets out of that one!
Okay, help you...
Help...
Help Ulysses is the best one.
Tell everyone you know.
If you're trying to...
If you're trying to get more tickets, Help Ulysses is the best bang!
For...
Your...
Bu...
Because it gives you as many tickets as you score.
I wonder if I could download an auto-clicker right now.
Okay...
One more.
Yeah, I have an auto-clicker on my normal computer for a cookie clicker.
Okay...
Oh my god.
My hands hurt.
Okay.
I can't tell if it's gonna scam us again or not.
Let's try it.
It's actually... It's a scam!
It's a scam!
Hey, can I get my vouchers back?
Wait, so do I actually have to...
I should probably... Okay, hold on.
I only have... What?
How many vouchers do I have?
I don't know.
We'll never know.
Oh!
Oh, I don't know.
A voucher to get a handheld gaming console from the prize machine.
I have two?
Okay, let's go to the past and try it.
I suppose.
Oh, wrong room.
Two should be enough.
Probably.
But also, I have this tradable item.
I wonder what we trade it for.
Unless...
Hold on.
Before I do this...
Let's go to... Let's go to Firecracker Kid and see what he's got.
Maybe I'll get another Firecracker Kid.
Maybe I'll get another Firecracker.
Or... Or, or, or, or, or...
Oh wait, he's not there, is he?
He's only there after school.
Or, or, or, or...
You can repair the rest of the machines?
I repaired all of them!
I got an achievement for it!
Yeah, he's not here.
Or, or, or, or, or, or...
Okay, I'll stop stalling.
Or, or, or,
or, or, or, or, or...
I can't say whore because I think my stream will get age-restricted, maybe.
Okie dokie.
Let's go.
So, to the arcade.
What?
Let's go to the...
I can't remember what doors work and what don't.
Let's just go to the basement and go through the vent.
Excuse me?
He's not in here, is he?
Hammer.
Yeah, what about the ham...
What do you mean?
Wait, I'm confused.
What do you guys mean?
Is the hammer not in the prize machine in the past?
The hammer is in the arcade, is it not?
But it's in the past, right?
Yeah, the one hitting the kid!
Right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right.
Okay, stop.
Okay, we're good, we're good.
Wait, was there a hammer in the present?
I'm so confused.
I'm so sorry, I'm so confused.
There's a hammer in the present too?
Really?
Okay, let's go check real quick.
Let's go check real quick.
Wee woo raid.
Wee woo.
Thank you.
I didn't see a raid notification, but thank you!
Thanks for the raid!
I don't know who it is, but thank you!
There is!
Broken.
And it would have been just when I was looking for it.
Okay.
So, you guys were correct.
It technically is here.
But we must grab it in the past.
We must grab it in the past.
Okay.
No, now we know.
Now we know.
And Springtrap might have left by now, so that's good.
Let's go back here.
We're gonna go through the basement.
So I can check and see if we're safe in there.
Oh my god.
What am I hearing?
What was that?
What the hell did I just hear?
What?
What was that?
What did I just hear?
The kid's still crying.
Uh-oh.
Wait.
Oh my god.
Chica, Chica, Chica, Chica, Chica, Chica!
Ah!
Hide!
Get in there!
Eyeswalled!
Oh my god.
Swat the spiders.
What are you talking about?
S...
A...
D...
That's not wise, dude.
Hey, I have spiders.
Oh my gosh.
Don't.
Yeah, I know you're gonna go that way instead.
Yeah, exactly.
Okay.
Who just came in?
Anybody?
Oh my god.
Chica.
Oh!
Oh my god.
Chica.
Please leave.
But go...
Not that way.
Go to the right.
Okay.
Chica, please stop camping.
Where does this go to?
Oh, the storage.
That's right.
I guess I could technically...
Okay.
Oh gosh.
All right, let's grab the hammer.
That's a big hammer.
Put it in my hammer space.
Hammer.
Perfect for smashing.
Yeah, I'll just smash the animatronics.
Okay.
What is this?
Well, let me do this, I wonder.
What the?
Pick up the balloons?
Wait, this is a game?
Ew.
Wait, why is it...
Why is it move like this?
What the hell is this game?
Huh?
Wait, why is there a game on the vending machine?
Why do I sound like SpongeBob?
What is this?
Oh, I don't have to smash.
It's a spam it.
Okay.
How many balloons are there?
Oh.
There's nothing in this room?
Okay.
Secret minigame.
Interesting.
Four?
Four.
4x4 4x4 4x4 4x4 4x4 4x4 4x4 It does sound like Spongebob.
It does, right?
Oh, oh gosh.
Wait!
Oof.
The eye is on Golden Freddy.
4x4 4x4 4x4 4x4 4x4 4x4 4x4 4x4 Four...
Six?
Why is it turned purple?
Oh, okay.
Is something coming after me?
I'm a little scared.
I keep getting caught on the tables.
Where do I go?
Do I go to Golden Freddy?
Jump scare incoming?
No...
What's this?
Left in the room south of there.
New door open.
Alright, Spongebob.
Six.
See you.
Oh shoot.
Later.
It's me.
Stop.
That'll be Golden Freddy.
Maybe we're okay.
See you later.
Fuck.
I hate this.
Got it.
What if I did the cutscene?
Anyway...
I can't see anything.
I actually can't see a single thing.
Am I able to move?
I don't know what's happening.
Oh.
You saved me.
Run to the exit before.
Um...
Wait, what's going on?
What's going on?
Escape.
Oh my god.
Oh shoot.
Ah!
Do I have it in my inventory?
Wait.
Are we in the pre...
We're in the past.
I mean we're in the present.
Oh, man.
Oh my god.
Okay, I have to go do all of that over again.
Oh gosh.
Oh man!
I don't have it.
Yeah, because we have to go get it in the past.
The balloon game all over again too?
Ah!
You're right!
Lame.
How did we get there before?
You know what, I'll just go.
Oh, that's Bonnie's hand.
That was Bonnie's hand for sure.
Let's just go through the party hallway.
Why did they have to turn off the lights then?
Never mind.
I hear someone else.
Oh gosh, this is going to be pretty risky.
I'm not going to lie.
I think he's...
I think we're okay.
Oh shoot.
No, we're not okay.
We're not okay.
I maybe could have run for it.
No, no, no, please don't go to the arcade.
No!
No, Springtrap, please!
Turn around!
No, no, no!
Auto-saves on nights four to five suck, so be careful.
Okay.
I couldn't see.
I had the flashlight on, but I ran...
I was taking you, asshole!
But I ran past it.
It's my fault.
Oh my god!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Actually, this might be good.
Because we'll call him out.
Here he comes.
Maybe he'll go to the right instead.
Maybe he'll leave the arcade.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Go that way.
And go down.
That would be even better.
Go down.
Nice!
Okay, now we have to hope that Chica...
is not in the arcade either.
Fuck you!
And what if I move?
Oh.
Is he in here?
I heard something.
I think we're okay.
Don't turn off the lights, please.
Okay.
So before it was just unlucky timing, I think.
Dude!
Oh.
Got it.
Oh, so that's what happened.
Are you okay, girl?
Are you okay?
So that's what took so long.
You saved me.
Run to the exit before...
Okay.
Wow, she did not even...
Oh my god.
Here.
Yeah!
Okay.
But now I can see.
So it's okay.
I can't believe she didn't even...
She didn't even thank me.
She just said, you saved me and left.
It just keeps getting worse and worse.
This ends tomorrow on the fifth night.
Animatronic characters get a bit quirky at night.
Oh, this is not my house.
This is school.
No!
Oh, this is my house.
No.
Oh.
Go to the ball pit.
Did I sleep all day?
I'm running out of time.
No more school.
No more distractions.
I'm bringing dad home.
Interesting.
So it's daytime.
Is he wandering around?
You think?
There's no way I can sleep now.
Where is my cat?
I also can't tell if it's too stressed out to sketch something right now.
I can't tell if he's wandering or not.
What about breakfast?
Guess we'll leave.
What was that?
Did the door glitch?
We're also missing one more item of my dad's.
The laughing kids, other than the pizza's phone number.
Why are there kids laughing in my basement?
And where's my cat?
Was there something under the table?
No, it just...
It's breezy.
So it does that for some reason.
I'm not quite sure why.
You can see it.
It's kind of rustling.
Oh my god.
I can hear him.
Let's just leave.
What is this static-y sound?
Scary.
Where's my cat?
Where is my cat?
Oh no!
It's amazing that the human body can live without the frontal lobe, you know?
Oh my god.
When I go in there, I'm not sure if I'll come back out.
Don't say that, Ozzy!
But I guess I'm as ready as I'll ever be.
Hold on.
My throat is really starting to kill me.
It's me!
I forgot the minigame!
Oh shoot.
I was so concerned about Chica, I forgot the minigame.
You think it's okay?
Does it unlock like a secret ending or something?
Oh.
Hello.
What are you doing?
You're chowing down.
You're chomping.
The cat is in another pizzeria.
Trade with Jet.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's do that.
Thank you for reminding me.
How many endings are in this game anyway?
What the?
Oh sh...
Okay.
Well, never mind, guys.
Never mind.
Where is Jeff anyway?
Jeff?
Three bad, two good.
I'm guessing I have to collect all my dad's stuff to get one of the good endings.
Thanks.
That doesn't spark confidence.
What?
Why is it locked?
Of all times for Jeff to actually lock this door.
I better hurry up and find him.
No.
No more running.
What?
This is not running.
This is backstage.
No,
no, no.
Was he in here?
Jeff!
I'll have to explore a little bit more.
I hope you guys don't mind then.
Is he in here?
Oh yeah, we haven't seen...
Jeff!
Okay, he could be doing way worse things in this office.
I'll be honest.
What you doing there, Jeff?
What's it look like, kid?
Working.
He's playing extreme solitaire.
What are you doing barging into my office?
I need to get into the ball...
I mean, I left my jacket in the room of the ball pit the other day.
Can you let me in there?
Can't wait to see you on an aircraft carrier.
Yeah!
Ha, nice try, kid.
You're wearing the exact same jacket you wore when you went in.
No, I'm not.
This is my backup jacket.
Nice save, Ozzy.
The other one has my wallet.
I kinda need it to buy pizza.
Oh yeah, that's pretty important.
Here, take the key.
But don't go playing around in that ball pit again.
I promise I'll stay out of there as soon as I'm done.
Never want to see that thing again anyway.
That's gross, huh?
You have no idea.
What else is in here?
Stay out of the gross pit.
I get pink-eyed just from looking at it.
Okay.
Look, it has even some of the little stars up top.
I...
For some reason, read that as Fredbear's frickin' show.
I was like...
Oh my god.
What the?
Is it... am I... I can't tell if I'm actually...
Oh my god, he's actually chasing me!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, oh my god, he's actually chasing me!
It was... I was taking too long!
I'm sorry, game, I'm sorry!
Oh my god, please.
Oh, but...
What the?
You guys, the prompt was not showing up.
Why was the prompt not showing up?
The prompt was not showing up!
You saw that, right?
Oh my god.
No way, I have to go through all of this again.
This is so stupid.
Maybe that's why he's not here.
Because he's at the pizzeria.
My papa.
Dad's underwear.
Oh, I can get the fireworks now!
Okay, blessing in disguise, right?
And also, let's search for the cat a little bit.
I don't see our cat.
I don't see the cat.
Oh gosh.
The Game Over music gives Metroid Prime vibes.
Where's our cat?
In the attic, maybe?
Why are all the lights flickering?
Cat!
I'm really worried about him.
The cat is under the table.
No.
No, he's not.
The table does this regardless.
The table does that even when there's nothing under there.
Is there a reason to find the cat?
Or is it just for good cat vibes?
For good cat vibes.
Okay, let's go to the library first.
Oh, he's not even here!
Maybe they gave you... maybe if you don't go into the attic, they gave the handheld as an extra tradable, you know?
Just in case.
Probably.
School, maybe.
Because the attic one, you don't really have a reason to go into the attic once it's boarded up.
So there wouldn't be a reason to find the Freddy mask, you know?
I think.
Closed?
Not sure I want to be showing my face around here.
Wait, why is the school closed?
Is it Saturday?
Home?
Oh, OK.
Anyway.
Let's go to... I'll check out the mill just in case.
As well.
The Freddy's mask is luck-based.
Oh, really!
Lucky us!
Okay, nothing else here.
Cool.
Let's go look for pizza.
Ugh, my nose!
Oh, I have some medicine here.
I'm gonna take some.
I don't think it'll stop my throat from hurting,
Let's go.
You got caught in the corner of the ladder.
That's why it didn't show up.
I'll take some cough drops.
Or I'll get another cough drop after this.
I don't know.
Hopefully it's just allergies.
Honey lemon tea.
Yeah, I'm gonna take it easy today, mostly.
So that I...
don't push it too much.
Especially before the concert, you know?
Oh my god.
Hello!
What you doing there, Jeff?
I'm working.
What are you talking about?
Oh, had to start locking doors because some hooligans keep sneaking in and leaving those balls all over the place.
You wouldn't happen to know anything about that, would you?
No!
I mean, no.
I have no idea.
I mean...
I do not need to get into the ball.
I mean, I left my jacket in the room with the ball...
in the ball pit the other day.
Can you let me in there?
Okay.
Sorry, I didn't realize it would be a different thing.
A different dialogue.
Okay, here we go.
I know nothing about ball pits.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
That scared me so bad!
Run!
There we go.
Wait, is he gonna start keep chasing after me even as I come in here?
Oh my god, he is!
God!
Fine dad!
He must be in the party room, right?
Oh my god, he's fast!
Fast!
This is so annoying.
The auto-save.
Okay, I understand what you meant by the auto-save now.
But was it locked?
I didn't see if there was a prompt or not.
I don't think you can save in this game, right?
It's only auto-saves.
Use the ticket machine to save.
Oh, okay.
I was gonna say once I get the key, but he starts chasing after me, so we'll just do it here.
Okay.
I don't understand.
Oh wait, you meant this ticket machine.
Not the voucher machine.
Oh.
You guys, it won't let me.
You guys?
It won't let me.
Play some games?
I think I have tickets though, don't I?
Unless I used all of them.
Do you have any tickets?
I thought I did.
Let's see.
I just need to play this one twice.
Oh god, I was so close!
I was so close!
So Kinki, I just saw that you said you finished your icing.
Nice.
You're making a cake for your grandma?
How are you real?
Yippee!
My postcards came today, they're so cute.
Thank you!
Oh, okay, nice.
Okay.
Okay, it's saved!
Everybody, we're safe, we're safe.
We're good.
So I thought it was similarly to like the...
You know where...
Where it says like escape, you just run to the ball pit?
I thought it was gonna be the same where it's just like, find dad.
You just run to where dad is, you know what I mean?
What you doing there, Jeff?
What's it look like, kid?
Working.
If you barged in here to ask about the room with the ball pit...
No, I'm not opening the door.
Huh?
What are you talking about?
I'm just gonna lock the door, the hooligans.
Yeah, the hooligans.
Okay.
Alright, we get the key.
Yeah, I'll try hiding this time.
Maybe... I wonder if I can like... make it...
Okay, here we go.
Just run.
Gosh!
Oh!
I got a bit of a... sprint there.
Oh my god.
Run, run, Oswald.
Run.
Ozzy, Ozzy, Ozzy, Ozzy.
Okay, okay.
And keep going!
Keep going!
Oh my god, it's so scary!
I'm gonna try and do the same thing I did before.
If Chica's here, I'll just run past her and then I'll hide instead of trying to open the door.
Oh my god!
No, no, no!
Nooooooo!
It's done.
Holy cow!
Okay, I'm just gonna hide then.
I'm just gonna hide.
The guy is so fast!
That QTE!
I...
This is Night 5, everybody.
This is true Night 5 gaming.
Happens if you run back to Jeff.
Should we see?
I wonder if the door is locked.
Might be kind of fun, though.
Why are you here?
The vent is safer?
Oh, okay.
Um... which vent would be good to go to?
Maybe the one where Freddy Fazbear is.
This one?
Swat the spiders!
D!
A!
F!
S!
Oh my god!
That was so close!
Holy moly, that was close!
The phone is ringing.
I think it's security.
But of course he's gonna go in there.
Dad item?
Wait, where?
I don't see it.
Please.
Bottom right?
Hello?
I'm not sure if it's the same person working here.
Honestly, five days is a long time for someone in this position.
So I'm sure you are doing great.
But as a tradition, if you have decided to move on to other things, just make sure that you pass on the important notes to the next person.
To help them settle in, like what I did to you.
Middle right?
Oh!
Are you kidding me?
Come on, Chica!
Middle right.
I don't see anything.
We'll wait for Chica to leave the other room as well?
Oh my gosh.
Okay, please leave.
Thank you.
See the blue in the bottom right?
Kind of.
I think so.
That is so hard to see.
Come on!
Chica.
She's being quirky.
Dad's name tag from work!
Oh my gosh.
Get in there.
Find all the clues about dad!
Okay, let's see what it is.
Dad's name tag.
Dad's name tag from work.
He was so upset to lose his job at the mill.
Hello.
My name is dad.
It wasn't his fault.
But that didn't stop him from telling mom how ashamed he felt.
Awww.
Dad looked so sad when he told me I lost his job at the mill.
I didn't understand why he kept saying I'm sorry.
I never thought it was his fault.
Dad always worked so hard.
Did you redo the balloon game?
It feels important because it has the restaurant layout.
No, I haven't.
Not yet.
Probably should do that.
I'm glad he's my dad.
God.
This game.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
So we probably will get to that door and it's going to be like, I need a...
Also, question.
Did anybody see when I grabbed that if it saved?
When I grabbed this name tag, did it save?
Because...
I hope so.
I didn't see her.
No idea.
That's okay.
I wonder if I can save in here.
Nope.
Oh, there's only one room left where dad could be.
I need to find him.
Okay.
Hopefully.
I don't want to have to do everything all over again.
Okay.
They said trading a voucher auto saves.
Yeah, but it's like...
Annoying, you know?
I don't think it'll let me go back through the ball pit.
I think he's going to be like, no, I have to find my dad.
You know what I mean?
We have to go to the party room.
All right.
It's raining.
That's raining even.
Um...
What would be the best way?
The arcade is kind of hard because there are no hiding spots.
Honestly, through the storage or through the dining area...
Through the storage is probably the easier way.
But, the arcade first.
Okay, we'll try.
Okay, we'll try the balloon game first, you guys.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Let me...
Give me a second.
It's just the one game, right?
That there is?
I don't hear anyone.
Oh my god!
You guys, it's a good thing I didn't go to the arcade.
I'm just saying.
I think...
They added the sound of rain so I can't hear them walking around so much.
I think they added the sound of the rain so I can't hear them walking around so much.
Can you please leave?
Actually, what if I go from here?
Alright.
SpongeBob.
SpongeBob SquarePants.
Boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop.
There are multiple secret mini-games.
Oh, interesting.
Well, maybe playing just this one won't change an ending, but we'll see.
And then this is the front door area.
And then this is the dining hall.
Are you ready, kids?
Aye, aye, Captain.
I can't hear you.
Oh.
Who lived in a pineapple under the sea?
William Afton.
And this is the stage.
This is the backstage of the stage.
This is the ball pit.
I don't remember where the last one is.
Wait.
Oh, this is the kitchen.
Oh, here it is.
Aha!
I see, I see.
It opened up.
And this is the party room.
And inside the party room is... a dog.
And... what?
See you.
What the dog doing?
I don't know.
Eating that guy, I guess.
Oh, my gosh.
It scared me.
Let me out of here, you stupid rabbit!
Hey, are you alright in there?
I was locked in here by some strange rabbit.
Can you find a way to get me out?
I'll find something.
Okay.
So, it's not even my dad in there.
Oh, my gosh.
That was Chico, wasn't it?
Um... find a way to get her out?
How do I get her out?
Well, the ticket machine in the past let you save also.
I'm not sure.
I don't know.
What do I need to get her out?
Looks like... there's like a little red light.
Maybe it's a key card?
Or something?
Uh...
Oh, my God.
Please.
I can't stand listening to you anymore.
Oh, we're in the basement.
Oh, my gosh.
I forget where this one goes.
Maybe in the security room.
Oh, shoot.
Who just walked in here?
Does it show me?
Looks like the door opens with some kind of key card.
What kind of party room is that secure?
Okay, so it is a key card.
So, it may have been...
Will it be Springtrap, the Patriot's creation?
Or Oswald, Springtrap's play stick?
Our beloved monsters.
Well, maybe in security room, then.
Why is the objective still find dad, though?
I'm really worried about dying because of how...
I don't know if anything is saved.
No!
You have to go to the freezer to cool down the key card?
Oh, gosh.
Maybe if I check the cameras?
My room.
Springtrap's go into the...
To there.
Arcade is dark.
It's dark for some reason.
Dining area is dark.
Oh, they're always dark.
Look!
Look at the membership.
Thank you!
It's weird that we're in cam 7 but we can't hear her, you know?
We can't hear her being like...
I'm not sure!
Oh my god, please.
Don't do that to me.
I'm not sure!
A door!
A keycard.
I guess we'll just have to explore for it, right?
I'm nervous.
I'm gonna see if anybody comes out because I'll go into the arcade and see if... wait.
I have a voucher but...
I don't know how many tickets I have.
I don't think I have enough tickets to get a new voucher.
No, guys!
Oh, guys!
Oh, golly, golly, guys!
You guys!
Okay.
I don't think I have enough tickets.
The cool is.
I'm officially out of drink.
Actually, no, that's a lie.
I have a water bottle.
I'm gonna go grab it.
Give me a second.
I'm gonna grab my water bottle and I'm also going to go to the bathroom real quick.
Because I've been drinking so much to try and keep my...
my throat hydrated but it's also making me have to go to the bathroom.
So, BRB for like a minute.
Give me one second.
Okay.
Potty break, everybody.
Let's all go to the little ghost's room together.
But separate stalls.
Okay.
Bye-bye for a second.
I am back.
Okey-dokey.
I have a question.
When you guys go to the bathroom in like your own house, do you shut the door?
If you're home alone, you know?
Or do you...
leave the door open?
Do you wash your hands?
Yeah, of course.
Yeah, I shut the door.
If home alone, why?
I don't know.
Like it feels wrong...
to leave the door open even if I'm home alone.
You know?
Like...
Like here...
I...
I'm in my own hotel room, right?
By myself.
But I still shut the door.
It feels so right.
What?
To shut it?
Or...
I have pets.
No such thing as alone.
My...
My cats don't care about if I'm going to the bathroom.
What if someone breaks into your house while you have your door open?
That's what I was...
Oh my gosh.
You...
I was literally thinking the same exact thing.
I was like, what if someone...
bursts into my home and I have my door wide open?
I leave the door open singing, leave the door open.
I'ma leave the door open.
Okay.
What kind of...
A key card.
If I were a key card...
Now, I don't think we go back to the present because the door for the party room is blocked off in the present.
So why would there be...
Why would there even be, you know, a reason to have a key card in the present?
Oh my gosh.
Holy crap.
You guys are killing me.
You guys are killing me!
Oh my gosh.
Where else?
Where, where will it be?
The thing you said about Oz not wanting to return to the present is correct.
Okay.
Yeah.
I figured that was going to be the case.
If I were a key card...
I was...
Where would it be?
We've done the kitchen?
We've done... like the...
Enjoy the rest of the game.
Thank you!
Oh my gosh.
Chica.
It's in a really weird spot.
Okay.
Perhaps the basement.
We'll go look.
I guess we just gotta kind of look around.
And see where it's been dropped, I suppose.
Shaking down the guard.
You guys...
Do I have brain rot or do you?
Chica, please leave.
Get out of here.
Thank you.
Can I get a pita?
Pita.
The chicken is here.
No.
Now I have to wait for her to leave again.
Cause that's where I gotta go.
Oh my god.
You guys just don't quit it.
We learned it from you, dad.
Oh, this is gonna be aw- You know what?
I think I have to do it.
Thanks for the 20 gifted!
Okay.
How do you always run right to where I'm under?
Without even knowing where I am.
Huh?
Oh, that's kind of...
Stop!
Go away!
Okay, so I think he just went into the kitchen?
And Chica...
Went into the kitchen.
What the?
Wait.
They won't let me backstage!
Okay.
Interesting.
Okay, interesting, interesting.
So they're...
They're partying it up there.
In...
Okay.
So the keycard is not in the basement.
Unless...
It is in the basement and I have to...
I probably have to...
Okay.
I have to get there through the vents.
Which vent does it again?
The party hallway.
Oh, shoot.
Okay.
This is the party hallway door, right?
Yes.
Please don't be in here.
Oh, okay.
It's just Chica.
Oh my gosh.
Scared me.
Scared me so bad.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gooooood.
All right, now you get out of here, go to the kitchen where you belong.
Okay.
Actually, why would a rabbit belong in the kitchen?
I don't even understand that.
I don't understand my own joke.
Weird.
Anyway.
Rabbit soup.
Oh, what's that?
Eat?
Best to leave this alone?
Worry the... oh.
I thought it was sparkling.
That's why.
Let's check in here.
Where did all these things come from?
Is that the keycard?
Dang it, I thought that was... whoa!
Endoskeleton galore.
Okay.
It looks like there's something shoved inside one of them.
Is this the... is this it?
I got it.
I got it!
Ah, he's in.
Springtrap's in here.
Give me a second, you guys.
Give me a second.
Is he gone?
I don't hear him.
But I didn't hear a door open either.
Oh my god, we're finally in here.
Thank you.
I thought I was done for.
Before you get out of here, I'm looking for my dad.
Have you seen him?
No, I haven't seen anyone else.
But I'm... I've been here.
I'm hearing weird noises coming through the vent in here.
I definitely heard a man mumbling.
And snoring?
Oh man, that's gotta be him.
I think you're clear to run straight to the exit.
Just be careful.
Okay.
Good luck.
Oh, it's saved!
Oh, good it saved, you guys.
Nice.
What's in here anyway?
Don't touch that.
Alright, into the vent we...
What's this?
A photo!
Looks like it's pretty scratched up.
Wait, what?
Strange photo?
An odd photo of two men inside of a strange office.
Is this somewhere inside of Freddy's?
Interesting!
Dad!
Dad, you're alive!
Who's looking at me?
Dad?
Are you awake?
Oh.
Dad.
Come...
Come on, Dad.
Sounds like something's trying to get in.
I better hide.
But what about Dad?
He's...
Sleep stand...
Oh.
No!
No, you're not taking him away again!
Oh my god, you're so brave, Ozzy.
What else is in here?
Anything else?
No?
Okay.
Where are we?
The basement?
Great.
That bear is out there.
Oh.
Okay.
What does that mean?
Wait, I just realized...
This is just a covert assignment.
Hold on.
Where are we?
Oh.
We're just...
Somewhere.
What do I do with Freddy?
Freddy's blocking the door?
We gotta take his hat.
Isn't that what the book said?
We gotta do something with his hat?
Wait.
Sketchbook.
Um...
No...
Glue hat to head.
Um...
Oh!
The flashlight!
Never mind!
That's the flashlight!
What do I try now?
Oh, okay.
Just kidding.
Um...
There's nothing over here.
Uh...
Go after Springtrap?
Do you...
What do you think I'm doing?
What do you think I'm trying to do?
Where do you think Springtrap went?
Why do I...
Why can I still hear the girl?
Wait a second.
So...
But where did he go?
That's the issue.
Um...
Save that.
Maybe I check the cameras?
Oh my god!
So cheap.
What the...
Oh.
Oh!
The ball pit's down.
Uh...
I guess we'll go try the ball pit.
It's saved, so I'm not so concerned anymore.
We'll see.
Oh my god!
Wait.
I dropped something.
Oh my god!
It's kind of awesome.
The animation is so awesome!
Oh wait.
Did he see the photo?
Do you think he saw the photo of... of, like, William Afton, right?
And it freaked him out?
Was that the photo I dropped, I wonder?
Oh!
So it's a good thing I picked it up!
Dad!
No!
Not dead!
Please don't be dead!
Oh!
He's alive!
What the...
What the heck is that thing?
What happened, Oswald?
So I hid in the ball pit to play a prank on you, which I shouldn't have done!
You came to look for me and slipped on a ball.
Must have hit your head pretty hard when you fell.
I'm sorry, Dad.
I didn't mean for things to get so out of hand.
Yeah.
Well, we're just not going to explain the animatronic bunny there, right?
I accept your apology, Os.
But you're right.
You shouldn't have done it.
Let's get out of here.
Okay.
Go to the hospital, please.
You were...
You and I are beat up pretty good, Os.
What happened?
You don't remember anything?
Well, considering this massive lump on my noggin...
Nope.
Go to the hospital, please!
Oh...
I was mad at you for being like this.
It's too late to pick me up again.
So I decided to hide from you to make you feel as annoyed as I was.
You slipped on a ball and got knocked out.
I'm sorry, Dad.
But your arm...
Oh my gosh.
What if it's like a zombie virus?
Is he going to become Springtrap?
Oh, Os.
Yeah.
You...
You have a concussion, probably.
I'm the one who's sorry.
Things haven't been fair for you at all lately.
And it's up to me and your mom to keep you happy.
That hairstyle.
Must have hurt.
It must be genetic.
Os is going to grow up just to look like his dad, exactly.
He didn't get a single feature from his mom.
I certainly haven't lived up to my end of the bargain ever since the mill closed, so...
I think it's time your mom and I talk about moving somewhere better for all of us.
Even Grandma.
I'm sure there's industrial-grade bubble wrap out there just for her.
Aww.
Really?
Really.
Now let's get you patched up.
Dad.
By the way, I think I may be suspended from school.
What?
It's fine.
We're leaving.
Oh.
Achieve two-star ending in either creepy or frightening mode.
Yay!
What's a two-star ending?
Oh.
There's...
What the...?
What is this song?
Is this a song made for this game?
Is he a- is he saying The Pit?
Something from the Piiit...
Oh, voice is from the pits!
No way!
Oh, God!
There he is.
The pits are calling out to me you guys.
The pits are calling to me.
Voices from the pits.
Walkie walkie.
Wow this is so fun though.
Thank you for playing.
Thank you for letting me play.
No music.
Jeff's Pizza Dining Hall.
Freddy Fazbear's Dining Hall.
What else is there?
Oh Jeff!
That kid better not have gotten hurt in there.
Oh there's blood!
TV table straight thanks for the 10 gifted.
Uh oh.
Wait Jeff.
Jeff no.
Oh Jeff Jeff Jeff.
Oh Jeff no no no.
Jeff!
I knew that was gonna happen.
Rip Jeff.
Can we really consider that a good end?
Jeff did nothing wrong.
Actually but also Jeff did nothing right.
Oh you can't see because chat but I have two stars up here.
Nice.
There is a true end.
You saved Jeff for the third three star ending.
How do I save Jeff?
I fixed all the machines.
What else could I have done?
What else could I have done to save Jeff?
Hmm.
It's complicated.
Ah the secret mini games.
I have to play all the hidden mini games.
I see I see I see.
Voices from the pit.
Thanks for the five gifted.
Check the achievements.
Yeah let's check them.
Let's look at them.
Actually are they?
Yeah here they are.
Unlock all achievements.
Trip over 20 times.
Toddled babies 100 times.
Mystery.
Finish the game without turning on the flashlight.
Hiding not included.
Okay.
Complete the game without getting caught.
Master of s... Is that a box?
Is that a cardboard box?
I'd rather not.
Thanks for the five gifted.
Is that a cardboard?
Is that him hiding in a cardboard box?
Meet Jinx in a room 10 times.
Oh.
Triggered chicas a lot.
I don't know.
I agree.
Forgetting against all odds.
Get grabbed by Bonnie.
Oh I did that.
Oh.
These ones are...
Sorry.
Dial 911.
Mystery.
Not a gamer.
Honk Freddy's nose.
Give me five.
Find all the clues about dad.
The guys.
Bless you.
Thank you!
I should go blow my nose.
See ya, dad.
Left dad behind.
Achieve two star ending in either creepy or friendly way.
Geoff!
Geoff, I'm so sorry!
Hide and seek world champ.
Use hiding spot one time while being chased without getting caught.
Oh, use each hiding spot one time.
While being chased.
What the hell?
I wonder what the secret ones are.
The hidden ones.
Maybe stuff about like the minigames.
The other minigames and...
Yeah, when a chase is ongoing, it seems kind of...
Can't believe Mint left me to die.
No!
Poor Geoff.
We can... you know, we don't know if he... we don't know if he died.
Right?
Because like...
Springtrap was still... was still... you know...
He was still stuck in the ropes.
He could have just jumped at Geoff and Geoff went, Wow!
And I'm sure Geoff has really good like instincts and reflexes, you know?
He probably slammed the door shut really, really fast and then like bolted out of there.
I'm pretty sure he's good.
The rope broke?
Where is your evidence?
Started breaking in the cutscene.
No!
Of these ones though, I'm still so interested about...
We never got one with Freddy.
Like...
I never even really had to see Freddy.
I should have shined my light at Freddy at one point.
Oh well.
Yay!
It was so fun!
That was really fun.
I liked how it introduced so many different parts.
And then also how...
Like...
Like the different...
What's the word?
Game mechanics, I guess?
And then also like the...
I wish there was kind of more to do with the security cameras because...
It kind of felt like there was no purpose.
I didn't really feel like there was too much of a purpose for them.
They were just there to be like...
Haha!
Do you get it?
It's FNAF!
But...
I liked it a lot.
Even though it was so goofy sometimes.
Even with the glitches, it was still nice.
What's that?
The extras.
Oh my god!
Stop!
Stop it right now!
We got all the stickers and everything too.
That was good.
The animatronics.
The sprites look amazing.
They look so, so good.
Look at them!
Question mark.
Why doesn't he wave either?
Chica...
Bonnie...
Freddy...
Okay, I'm gonna go to the jump scares, you guys.
I'm missing one inventory?
I am?
I don't see it.
Game over.
9-5 ball pit.
Wow!
Oh my gosh!
The animations are just so awesome!
Oh, I was wondering who was on the security camera.
So it was Springtrap.
I keep saying Springtrap.
I have no idea if it's actually him or not.
Alternative music.
Beat nightmare difficulty.
Arcade minigame pizza roller.
Arcade minigame hat game.
Wait, but I did hat game.
Music man!
If you're like a fan of FNAF, there's definitely probably way more things than I noticed that like you would...
Be like, wow!
This is so cool!
You know?
Jeff's Pizza Creepy.
Let's listen to it.
There's a secret with Balloon Boy's game, but I got it!
Oh, that's right.
I didn't beat it.
I saw the secret, but I don't think I actually didn't complete it.
This is so cute!
I can't wait for Halloween.
Okay.
Thank you guys for hanging out with me today.
I actually do have to go get ready because I do.
I have one to go out for a little bit and go shopping just a little bit.
So I'm going to go do that.
Thank you guys.
It's kind of...
It's pretty late now, isn't it?
What time is it on the East Coast?
It's almost 1 a.m.
Holy moly.
Cool, cool, cool.
I'm just...
Okay.
That's the end of the game and thanks for the stream.
Thank you guys!
Thanks for hanging out with me.
Sorry, I was just checking.
I haven't checked my phone and people are, like, messaging me.
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Sorry, everybody.
Sorry.
I'm going to head out now.
And thank you guys for hanging out with me.
I will see you guys.
I don't know if I'll be able to...
I'm not quite sure when I'll be able to stream next.
As soon as I know.
It might be, like, two days.
In two days from now.
Japan time.
So maybe, like, Monday.
Monday.
Oh, wait.
I'll have to see.
Oh, gosh.
My schedule is a little...
Because of the concert and because of some other stuff I have going on.
Like, I'm meeting with some friends as well.
General Dank!
Welcome to membership.
Thank you!
So...
But...
And then...
I'll actually be moving hotels in the next couple of days as well.
So...
It's like...
That's...
I'm, like...
Figuring out...
Because I stream in the morning, right?
Maybe I can wake up early and stream before I move hotels.
Probably.
I think.
I'll see.
Okay.
Bye.
Okie dokie!
Otsumito!
Have fun over there, Mint.
Thank you!
Now waiting for next ASMR where you explain FNAF lore.
I don't know FNAF lore.
Saying it now.
Good luck with the concert!
I'll be cheering from home.
Thank you, Dogstrings!
Yes!
Oh!
If you are not going to Anime MYC and you still want to see Minto in concert, there are streaming tickets available as well.
So...
Yes.
It's on Spawn.
Let me post a link.
Let me post a link in case you're just like, I want to get it!
Um...
Where is it?
Well...
Where is it and...
Oh, here we go.
Here we go!
Where is it?
Streaming ticket.
Come see me wiggle... at the concert!
Wiggle wiggle!
I jump and I twirl.
And I spin around.
Actually I don't know if I jump.
What?
Well I jump.
Will jump?
Who knows?
Will I do cart wheels?
Will I wiggle and jiggle?
That's for sure.
But will I spin?
Probably.
Because I love spinning.
I got my streaming ticket!
Can't wait to see your performance!
Thank you!
Oh, hold on.
Streaming ticket for AMIC concert.
Jiggle what?
I gotta jiggle my body.
Probably.
I always gotta wiggle.
Around, you know?
But yeah.
I think it'll be a lot of fun.
And we've been working very hard.
So... I think it will be a good time!
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
What else was I gonna say?
I think that's about it.
Don't... Okay.
We need like a twirl counter.
Because...
Once I get on stage, I just feel like I have to twirl.
So...
Maybe we should keep a twirl counter, you know?
How many times will I spin around?
I just feel the music, you know?
And I spin around.
The twirlies.
Yeah.
Batsu, if you go over 10?
Okay.
Oh gosh.
I'm gonna be... I'm gonna be like...
Stop.
I'm gonna be so self-conscious.
I'm gonna be like... Oh my gosh.
Don't go over 10.
3D?
Maybe.
But, you know...
I don't have like a...
Full 3D.
But, you know... I'm just a special guest.
So I think it's okay.
Probably.
But you can still watch me...
You know...
Run around.
And stuff.
I will be running.
Okidoki!
Okay.
I gotta go now.
Because I gotta go take a shower.
And get ready.
My hair is kind of...
Icky right now.
Oh.
I only go to this concert offline because they got Aircraft Carrier.
Because they didn't set it up.
See you there.
Why are you running?
Because I gotta go!
Bye bye!
Thanks for hanging out with me!
Thanks for...
I'm glad we could finish the game.
And I will see you guys...
Like I said...
When I am able to stream next.
I will put up a waiting room as soon in advance as I am able to.
Yeah.
Otsuminto everyone!
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
See you guys later!
Bye bye!
Have a good night!
Have a good day!
Bye bye!
See you later!